[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
they are here hooray yes it's another
saturday just a slight technical
difficulty just my obs program crashed
like a minute before i was supposed to
start streaming yeah she stresses out
when it comes to like what minute it is
i said man
give them time you know they'll wait a
couple minutes you know
yeah but i kind of get anxious just
sitting here waiting
once i get started i don't like waiting
for things these [ __ ] bums are just
sitting at home anyway
looking at the damn smart tv they could
wait a couple of minutes
yeah you're at home where they got they
got somewhere to be it's like a saturday
saturday and we got our [ __ ] drinks
all ready got one made for her
ran out of it ran out of damn this is
the one orange juice i didn't know i was
out i would have gone yeah well so but
you know but i got some of this [ __ ]
beautiful
um ginger and lemon tea
where did that come from i just had some
ginger tea back in there and i made it
[ __ ] sweetened it
got all kind of a little bit of lemon in
there it tastes chinese as [ __ ] man's
really
good put some of that vent put some of
that some of that in there it'd be like
a tokyo tea
even though that's not china is it like
a japanese
yeah whatever i call that [ __ ] a
shanghai
iced tea
i guess so it sounds pretty good i was
just gonna say our [ __ ] pantry has so
many mysteries i don't even know what
the hell is it
yeah there's probably all kind of like
drink mixes and stuff from like [ __ ]
10 years ago i don't even know it's in
there i know there's some real
um ginger tea huh back there i wonder
how long that's been there
for years i don't remember buying this
it's good though michael schaefer says
been drinking beer since one o'clock oh
my goodness you're ready to go
god damn ready to go the suit
everybody's up to i don't know if i
could
i'd be falling asleep by this point if i
started drinking four hours ago that's
why i only just started a few minutes
ago
hopefully it doesn't hopefully i don't
get too incoherent by then i'm still
like everybody i've gotten so many
messages like saying last
week's show was like the best show ever
and i'm just like
i'm so afraid to watch it i just like
what i can't even watch it back
yeah i just like i don't even want us i
don't even want to know what happened
it was i went back and looked you were
[ __ ] loopy as [ __ ] but you were
getting through it
i was yeah and i had this look on my
face like i had under everything under
control
i was like i was pushing you this way
and that when i was looking at the
audience which is funny because it's
usually the other way
yeah usually like usually you're just
like sitting there going
yeah we're taking care of each other
we're taking care of each other we're
watching each other's back
i guess so yeah well it's just like
because because i seriously woke up at
like four in the morning like on sunday
morning i was like
did i even finish the show did i even
turn the computer off what happened so
like
i didn't even know what happened she got
in bed
i made her a chicken salad sandwich i
had that [ __ ] already made up i made her
nice big
put it on toasted bread it's all warm
with that [ __ ] creamy chicken salad
that i had in there
had the tarragon had the little [ __ ]
shaved almonds in it it had the [ __ ]
dried cranberries in it and everything i
give that to her and she goes thank you
and she takes one bite
and then i look over about five minutes
later and that one sandwich is sitting
back on that plate again with that one
bite in it that was it she was asleep
so i said you don't want any more of
this you got it i said it all right
i just put it in i was probably so
exhausted you have to tour in the
morning well the next day you brought it
you brought me the sandwich in a bag
with one bite take it out yeah i didn't
even remember it wasn't even a bite it
was like a [ __ ] one-third of a bite
i probably wanted it because i was
probably really hungry just a piece of
the crust
the reason that i got so [ __ ] up was
because i hadn't eaten anything for like
probably five or six hours like before
we did the show
i made some i made some chinese pork
belly though oh it was really good
put that on it's a bit of ramen noodles
it's pretty good we've never made those
before no i don't think i'll be buying
any more of that though
that was a six dollar pork belly it was
good but
i'd rather buy six to six dollars of
[ __ ] something else
yeah you got it man it's good but you
know it's not
like that much better yeah yeah six
dollars a chicken is a lot better
more meat and that those big old pork
tenderloins i get from sam's
that's only like 15 bucks and that right
you know what i mean that's a lot of
[ __ ] lean
yeah we can eat off that for yeah at
least a couple weeks
so really here in the us the way it's
going right now
it's you're better to just go with a
bigger piece of a [ __ ] real high
quality meat make that investment right
there you really don't
i bought some ham hocks and they were
[ __ ] expensive they're they're
ripping me off for ham hocks that's why
trash food
well it used to be used to be now well
now everybody ramsay [ __ ] that [ __ ] up
now everybody's
foodies so yeah they know what to do
right you can't get away with it you
can't get away with it like you could
because now everybody knows how to get i
know what that is it [ __ ] pissed me
off they got yankees that know what that
is
ham hocks you can't make red beans and
rice without that [ __ ]
if it's good in black-eyed peas too and
it there
used to be you could get two ham hocks
for about a dollar fifty
those are that was back before [ __ ]
well yeah i remember that was like [ __ ]
nobody wanted that was like poor people
food
yeah only rednecks and black people knew
about it we knew how to [ __ ] we knew
how to eat that [ __ ]
and turkey decks yeah yeah i didn't know
about them
[Laughter]
his neighbor yeah his his name his name
his neighbor
brought was is this [ __ ] black chick
her her husband is a [ __ ]
um national guard guys so he's an nco
they found out i was army they're my
dad's ex-navy so they're like best
buddies
she was visiting him in the hospital and
everything for his heart transplant
or not your heart's transplant oh
[ __ ] what they call that heart bypass
and uh she brought him some chicken
necks
all right but that was when he was at
home yeah turkey
turkey and executed yeah he loves
chicken and he was telling me about
those turkey necks then he goes in there
and gets a surgery he comes out he goes
doctor put he put turkey necks in there
i said no he did not
well i saw him he put the turkey necks
in he did and he had me believe in it
it's like maybe it's some new experiment
yeah we don't know about it
his memory the miracle of turkey his
memory got [ __ ] up
he thought they had fixed his heart he
thought the bypass was made out of
turkey decks
and i was like nah man that was your
neighbor she was over here she was
talking to you before you went in the
damn
into the operating room and she was
telling me about the how you loved her
turkey necks and you were telling me how
good the turkey decks were
and then he's like i don't remember that
that's you and i said i don't believe
that
i don't believe that he put turkey necks
in here i had a roll on another show
it put turkey necks in there and they
said no they did not
i do not believe that that's your
prerogative
i'll never forget that and he forgets
that [ __ ] conversation you can't
remember
that's your prerogative poor guy yeah
i mean you know he just had his heart
like all rearranged
give him a break so what's today's show
this was kind of an interesting topic
this uh notably this is going to be the
last topic
that uh is not going to have like a poll
done to it so like i said if you're a
patron which most of you uh most you
guys in the comment section are right
now
um remember you still have until
tomorrow
at noon eastern standard time to vote on
next week's topic and next week's movie
retrospective
um so but this is the last one this was
actually recommended by somebody and i
can't remember who like a long time ago
and then i kind of like expanded it out
we're going
uh sort of true crime but we're also
doing renaissance
italy now first we want to talk about
the case
of beatrice
now this woman she was an italian
noble woman and um very famously she
conspired with other members of her
family to kill her father and was
executed in a pretty horrible way and
over the years subsequently she became
kind of this romantic tragic
figure um mostly because her dad was
like a giant gaping anus and nobody was
sorry that he died
and they thought that like she shouldn't
have been punished for it which i kind
of agree with
um but her case was kind of taken up by
like poets and artists and [ __ ] like
that like later on so she kind of
attained this sort of like legendary
status almost like a joan of arc
kind of thing you know what i mean yeah
and i found her case very interesting
and then while i was looking into her
case i was thinking i wonder is there
something else like that happened around
the same time period or something that
was kind of similar that i could add to
it
and i was like looking at i went down
one of those like wikipedia wormholes
now and i found like list of people
executed by the holy see
which you know which uh beatrice
achanchi was
and i found the case of julia tofana
who was a master poisoner may have been
responsible for the deaths of
600 men
also um hold on what
was that poisoner killed 600 people yeah
well not
directly but her poisons may have been
responsible for her so she was selling
poison
yes okay she is also because i
immediately had to call [ __ ] on that
if if you killed 600 men directly
through poison you would make it and
give it to people
it's only a matter of time before they
figure out that you're the link between
all them six
well they did figure it out yeah
eventually even if she was doing it but
she was running around
like for a pretty long time okay um and
we'll get into why that was like why she
got away with it for so long
um but yeah i found her very fascinating
too and it seems like neither of these
women
i i had heard of um beatrice because
um you know as i said there's been like
[ __ ] tons of
stuff written about her the charles
dickens wrote [ __ ] about her percy
shelley
uh nathaniel hawthorne there's been
plays about her operas all kind of [ __ ]
um i had heard of her because lucio
fulchi
made a movie about her in 1969.
um it's either called beatrice chanchu
or it's called i think the conspiracy of
torture
i started watching it because it's on
youtube for free but
there's not a dubbed version that i know
of like all the versions that are on
youtube
are in italian so i was like watching it
in italian with like the automatic
english subtitles and that word
wasn't working out so good so i was just
kind of like well i just kind of skimmed
through i'm like well i know the story i
got the gist
and also because i think i mentioned a
long time ago when i did my
review of david lynch's mulholland drive
he had a reference to her
like in the background of one of the
scenes he had like a portrait of her
hanging
uh because of the whole patricide uh
type of thing
so um so i kind of got interested in her
i thought it'd be cool to do a show
about it because we don't do like a lot
of historic like
i don't think we've done anything from
like renaissance period have we we've
done like other
we've done ancient stuff we've done
stuff from like the victorian era
i think we've mentioned it a couple
times but we haven't really focused in
on it because
remember we were talking about like all
the uh weird things that happened like
the [ __ ] dancing diseases and [ __ ]
yeah that's middle ages yeah yeah
there's a renaissance
we've done so many well i guess there's
some cross over there but uh yeah so
this habit like um
these two cases were basically were
mostly like very late
16th century early 17th century to get
some more ice in this [ __ ] look at that
look at how it's just sucking my eyes up
like that sucking your eyes out [ __ ]
my eyes
[Laughter]
oh you saw oh sandra you saw the varium
it was wasn't it awesome i loved that
[ __ ] movie it was so good actually i
want to see it again
this is the first live i follow i can't
[ __ ] believe you're talking about
someone with a name like me
well it's here's the thing for a long
time because in
english we would pronounce her name
beatrice
so for a long time i kind of just
figured that that's how it was
pronounced um even though i did like
study italian for a little while so i
knew that i said that's probably not how
the italians would pronounce it but
that's how they would pronounce it in
english
so i started watching other stuff like
about her that was
done in like uh by native italian
speakers
and uh i tried to pronounce it like
similar i don't want to be like
i don't i don't want to be like
pretentious and like like print out
stuff but i don't want to pronounce it
like super
wrong either what are you eating oh
you're going to ask me what i'm eating
no i just thought you just saw you
chewing it
on my way out i grabbed a piece of that
pork belly oh
there was some of that still in the pan
because i had some left over oh okay
it is very good it was it was it had
like a a really good like
caramel kind of it's very sweet it's
very sweet oh is that what it is oh yeah
it was honey garlic
um ginger extract ginger powder
um soy sauce
no one salt what they call it [ __ ] what
do they call that [ __ ]
white pepper chinese three spice or four
spices
just a little bit um five spice that's
what it is chinese five spices oh okay
but yeah so i thought these would be an
interesting show to do so like i said if
any of you
uh are italian and i pronounce anything
wrong i apologize
i did try to get it kind of close you
know
um you want to do a couple shout outs
before we do anything go ahead oh you
have to tell
the pookie story oh boogie you have to
this is so so funny our kitty is so
smart you guys
listen to this [ __ ] i walked out into
the uh into the entrance area where the
front door was on pookie was running
around in a circle
and i couldn't tell what she was [ __ ]
doing she go to the door and she go over
to the [ __ ] cat bowl
or the cat fountain and then she's
running around and then she gave up
whatever it was so i let her out
while she was out i noticed that the cat
fountain wasn't running
because the water had gotten too low
yeah we have a little water fountain yes
i filled it up
with some of that filtered water and sat
down in front of my television and i
could see the fountain where i was
i let her in she came in she ran back
out there and then she ran to saw the
fountain and did a little
jump yay
it's back she was trying she's trying to
tell me
daddy that the fountain had gotten too
low and it stopped running it wasn't
making water it wasn't making the
fountain
and she was getting frustrated that he
wasn't getting the message back yeah she
thought it wasn't coming back
no it's not coming back it's broken yeah
and she came back and she saw it she saw
it she stopped and she went she bucked
yeah a horse like a horse buck
like that and then went in a circle it's
back
she's [ __ ] hilarious man she's like
so funny she's so weird about water man
because we have like the little water
fountain
which runs constantly you know and then
we have the one
like on the other side of the house we
have the bowl that's attached to the big
jug that you can just like fill with
water
every time you refill that jug with
water she comes running because she
hears it
and then like she was and she'll sit
there and like watch the bubbles
like coming up with her head tilted like
that like watching the bubbles and then
all of a sudden she goes
and like reaches out with both her paws
and like wraps her little paws around
the [ __ ]
i've owned a bunch i've owned a bunch of
cats i've never had one like that
never had one she has quite a
personality yeah i think it's because
it's the only cat
we really i actually really kind of like
hand raised that we raised since she has
society and she's always been around
people never been away from people so
she knows how to communicate with people
and i know i know what she's trying to
tell me just by eye contact she'll stare
at me and go i know you i know yes she
gives you a look
is that what you want because she's on a
pattern i know what comes next
she's on a routine yeah about going out
where the food comes and this and that
and filling bowls up and this
and she tells me what to do do this do
that now it's time to go
it's all a routine yeah before you go to
bed she'll stare at you and be like you
make sure you have a little
make sure the bowl's full of food before
you go to bed because i don't want to
have to like step on your head
it's hilarious it's hilarious
and she has you know towel time in the
closet after you get out of the shower
very uncat like
throw the wet towel on her and she rolls
around in it yeah very uncat like
very much like a monkey she plays plays
with the
dvds in the [ __ ] shelter because she
wants me to come and [ __ ] grab her
yeah because she wants you to stop doing
yeah
it's just funny [ __ ] okay we gotta get
to the show oracle says when do we get a
pookie t-shirt i know i need to make one
yeah i just should i don't know it's
like i feel like we need to do a cartoon
of her
because i don't want to just like find
cliff art of a cat that kind of looks
like her i kind of want like an actual
one of her but i don't know i'll have to
think about something everybody's
talking about everybody's talking about
their cats
people asking for a [ __ ] poopy
spatula
fountain for the cat yeah yeah she drink
ours drinks out of the faucet and the
and the fountain she'll drink out of
both of them if the water's moving she
likes it
yeah i've heard that like that's that's
something that a lot of vets recommend
that you
you do because a lot of cats will get
dehydrated because they don't like
stagnant water
that's just i mean for obvious reasons
because in the wild you know stagnant
water can sometimes have like diseases
and stuff
so it's like they prefer running water
because they know it's fresh
so just um she really liked drinking out
of the bathroom sink and i didn't really
want to have to like i'll turn it on for
her if she's up there but i don't want
to have to like leave the bathroom sink
dripping all the time
yeah so we just got her a little yeah
they make a fire from that that'll
[ __ ] recycle that same [ __ ]
yeah you just change it just change it
out clean it the filter everywhere how
much was that thing
30 bucks 30 bucks it's worth it cast a
lot i mean you can get
cheaper ones you can get more expensive
ones i just got that one because it was
like not because some of the ones they
have are like kind of ridiculous looking
like
the flowers and [ __ ] on them put
filtered water in there right through
your little
i got those pictures that filters it a
filter and put it in there you only have
to really well you don't have to wash
the thing as much either
it's not like a damn stagnant bowl of
water where they're drooling in there
some by that circulation
seems to and there's filters in the
[ __ ] fountain
so it just seems to stay cleaner a lot
longer you just keep adding water to it
every two weeks you want to take it out
take it apart wash it off real quick put
it back together
yeah didn't like wash the filter out
yeah but yeah it's like you know it's
been
she still drinks out of the sink but you
know yeah she even sits in there and
lets the water drip on her and then
licks it off
yeah i don't understand that she's weird
she'll get in the damn sink and want you
to turn the water on and let the drips
drip on her that's weird i've never seen
she just like watches
watching in jail just crazy i guess it
just like tastes better i don't know
it's a game some kind of game
but yeah so uh oh i also had a couple of
shout outs we have two new patrons
this week uh lynx13
and cat so welcome you guys thank you
very much
also i want to give another thank you to
dominic for sending
us uh the movies he sent us heavy metal
and stand watching the stand again
dominic i tell you what
bro i was seeing that i saw it when it
was new on tv and i really liked it
a couple years ago almost about six
seven years ago
somebody uploaded it to youtube man and
i was looking at it on youtube i was
like man
this is the same [ __ ] movie this [ __ ]
thing looks like [ __ ]
i mean it just looked like something
that was filmed [ __ ] out you know on
a phone or something
this version this blu-ray version is
[ __ ] excellent it's like a beautiful
it's like a movie it looks great it's
just very enjoyable
so i want to thank you for that we
haven't seen the heavy metal yet that's
also on the list
i haven't seen that in a long time that
i remember that would be real good
but i haven't seen it since i was a kid
heavy metal yeah i don't think i have
but um i remember there's a lot of music
in it yeah
a lot of music in it um yeah it's
interesting because the stand
i think i saw it came out in 94 right uh
that it was on cbs
and um i think i maybe saw the first
episode but maybe that's it i can't like
i don't know it's all a blur
um you know i was in my 20s then and
like
i remembered not liking it all that much
but then when we were watching it again
last night i'm like wow this is actually
this is excellent i was like maybe i was
mixing it up with another one maybe i
was mixing it up with like the first
it and it's real close with it's real
close to the book
real close it is yeah it's from what i
mean i haven't read the book in a long
time but um
that's another one this makes me want to
go see uh by the stand
and understand uh the shiny yeah you
don't like the shading
tv series no but i want to see that
again
where did we watch it before i remember
was it on youtube
was it on youtube it might have been
youtube i want to see it again i bet you
i wonder if there's a blu-ray a good
blu-ray
uh version of it i'm sure there is and
it reminded me last night we were
watching the stand i'm like man
now this makes me want to watch uh rose
red because you didn't see that did you
i think that came out in the
early 2000s i want to say because i
think i was living in tampa when it came
out because i remember watching it when
i was in my apartment in tampa we saw
the first two hours and there's a lot of
army soldiers
the [ __ ] was i think came out in 94 so
maybe yeah i think 74 94.
and the uniforms are spot on you know i
got out in the end of 94 almost 95 is
when i got out of the army
and the the uniforms are spot on that's
that's exactly what we were wearing
um of course they're still running
around in jeeps
back in those in the 90s in the movies
they still had the army was still in
jeeps
and on tv now we didn't have jeeps jeeps
were gone everything was humvees
but you could they couldn't get them
they couldn't get home these that's why
you rarely ever saw them in movies
well yeah so it's like well we're just
gonna have to play with you
yeah and i had totally forgotten that
mcgarris directed the stand
yeah so yeah it was like way way better
than i remembered
yeah zack says isn't rose red just the
haunting of hill house essentially it's
stephen king's version of the haunting
of hill house he loves that book well
that means i got to see it
um but you know yeah i just want
you know the more versions of haunting
of hill house they want to make the
better because that's like probably my
favorite haunted house novel
and one of my favorite horror movies the
1963 version not the 1999 one that one
was that one
[ __ ] victor garcia says the stand remake
comes out in december
oh interesting i didn't know that yeah i
figured that would be a good time for
them to make like another because you
know
everybody's all up in like an
apocalyptic fiction type
stuff yeah you think there'd be another
version of that
um yeah i think it's just the apocalypse
i think it is well like i said it's but
it's gonna happen in slow motion it's
more it's more boring than the ones in
the movie yeah it's gonna be
very much in slow motion
and you know i want to be like a downer
but you know i know you [ __ ]
are into [ __ ] fear porn if you're not
you wouldn't be on his damn channel
it's gonna go just like rome it takes
generations long long
time for a civilization to [ __ ]
decline
you know they don't really collapse
overnight it's just a slow slight
decline
even rome divided up into a couple uh
divided into an eastern and western
empire the united states is going to do
something like that but it'll be
it'll take the rest of my life a lot of
these problems that you're seeing
they're not going to end this is this is
the way it's going to be it's going to
be like this from
from here on out and probably get worse
it's just the nature of of civilizations
this is just how it goes the few and
here's something you know
there's a dude he was a futurist i was
watching this [ __ ] program
and a lot of [ __ ] that he said [ __ ]
made a lot of sense and just kind of
stuck with me
he said no matter who you are throughout
history whether you lived in the 1300s
or the 1000s or the 1800s from your
point of view the future would be
totally unacceptable
a person from 1000 a.d would look at
today they'd see that [ __ ] was totally
unacceptable
a person from the from the 1800s would
think that today
is not acceptable it's over little
things
you know what i mean like [ __ ] they'd be
like oh no this ain't america or that
kind of [ __ ] you know whatever
wait a minute hold on christianity's
gone or oh this this group isn't in
charge or
oh my civilization no longer exists
where'd the saxons go
now it should be [ __ ] like that because
everyone's wider
everybody's [ __ ] whiners nobody is
just roll with it man
nobody nobody has successfully predicted
the future
and no one's been able to control the
future
so who you are right now what's to come
20 30 years from now you're not gonna
like it
well that's what you're not gonna like
well that's why i'm not worried about it
yeah it's so there's nothing you can do
about it i just [ __ ] deal with a [ __ ]
i have enough personal anxieties
like it's just like little [ __ ] that i
can't control to worry about like i'm
not going to worry about [ __ ] i can't
control i don't need more anxiety piled
on top of anxiety
even i have like a lot of buddhist
influence in terms of buddhist
philosophy and i'm just
embracing the suck this goes back to the
army if the [ __ ] sucks [ __ ] learn how
to make it
make it just embrace it you'll become
stronger the fact that the [ __ ] sucks
you'll overcome it you'll overcome it
and if you can't adapt to it then you
die it's all right
nobody will notice 20 years after you're
gone and with a year a few years after
you're gone nobody will even remember
you so it's not a big deal
well that's why i mean i know like a lot
of well no i mean i know a lot of people
get bummed out by that kind of stuff but
that's actually kind of like reassuring
that's really true yeah
because it's like well you know i can't
[ __ ] up anything too badly it's like you
know what i mean it's like
yeah it's not no one will remember [ __ ]
it's like no one's gonna remember that
[ __ ] it's fun
yeah all kinds it takes a lot of
pressure off yeah
yeah i mean [ __ ] there were [ __ ]
mass murderers and evil [ __ ]
that
existed thousands of years ago and an
average person today don't even know
they
don't even know their names anymore long
gone
yeah long ago so
it's all temporary
[Laughter]
it's true yeah the part three of that's
coming out some people have seen it
already
yeah i heard about that i had heard been
hearing about that for a long time i
can't believe they actually uh finally
got around to it yeah
midnight's edge reviewed it it was good
it was pretty good
i mean if they're gonna have that much
time
to work on it it better be [ __ ] good
well they didn't work on it that long
there's only a couple years well no but
i'm just saying that after all this time
yeah they said it fits in with the other
two and if you liked the other two then
then you'd like yeah you'd like it maybe
maybe we'll rent it
i think they want 20 something dollars
to rent it well if you wait a week or
two it'll probably go down to 6.99
yeah i mean that's usually well usually
you have to wait long it depends on the
movie if it's a big movie you usually
have to wait like that i love it i love
the
i love [ __ ] villain 10th 1-2 when i
was a [ __ ] kid i did two i love it
too i thought they were awesome
it's just it's so funny to see keanu
reeves and john wick now like when i
remember him from from that and also
from dracula
like him yeah going around john wick was
good man
yeah i'm glad keanu like redeemed
himself after all
oh and uh also i think i always uh i
already reminded people to
if you're uh a patron to go and vote
on the next topic for next saturday and
the next movie retrospective for next
friday
i have uh five choices for each thing
what i did today i decided that because
i don't just want to put
because you know i have like five
choices and then everybody will vote for
one and then we'll do a show about that
and then i don't want to put like the
same four choices that lost and then
like a new one
so what i did was i did these two little
boxes i got this little box
and this has all the topics and i got
this little box and this has all the
movies
and i just have them in there so what
i'm gonna do is every week
i'm gonna put up five i'm just gonna
pick five out of there
at random and then with the one that
gets picked that we do i'll just throw
that one away
and then i'll just put stuff back in
there so it's not gonna be like the same
choices every week you know what i mean
just to like mix it up i don't know that
was bothering me
so i had to do this big elaborate thing
today where i put all these slips of
paper in the boxes
uh also if you are a patron
you will get to see my first book review
show
which is going up tomorrow morning uh if
you're not a patron then you'll get to
see it monday morning
at uh 10 eastern standard time so uh
hopefully you guys will i already have
like several of those in the can
and i'm working on another book right
now that i'm going to be reviewing
shortly like in a few weeks so hopefully
you guys will enjoy that i'm going to
start putting them up every monday
so i'm excited about it i have a huge
[ __ ] pile of books back there i'm
going to review
yeah tom's not enthused no
[Laughter]
i don't read
[Laughter]
i'm not involved in that yeah somebody
said time to quote ozymandias and he's
like yeah the guy that wrote osmantius
is also and
interestingly percy shelley who wrote
osmandias also
uh wrote uh what probably the best known
poem about
be a churchy genji who is one of the
people that we're talking about tonight
you want to talk about this yeah all
right yeah
yeah i'm just i'm listening to the show
okay i'm listening to the show but
let you do your [ __ ] man let me do it
the alcohol is just starting to hit me
oh okay it's starting to look like yeah
you're [ __ ] with my buzz man
i'm [ __ ] with your butt [ __ ] with
my buzz i'm letting it it's it's
it's seeping in that was pretty [ __ ]
that was a pretty strong drink
okay so we're gonna start this well
let's start talking about this young
lady
okay all right now i've okay so i feel
like the legend
of beatrice achanchi um kind of as i
said it probably started
uh somewhat after she was executed
because i think there was kind of like
um
a lot of literary people like poets and
stuff like that that got really
uh that were really like uh taken by her
story
so they kind of took the story and ran
with it so the way that
the legend has come down to the modern
era
is fairly accurate but not
entirely accurate you know what i mean
this i mean the story of her
killing her abusive father and
you know going to the gallows or you
know go and get her head cut off like
unrepentant and all this other stuff
that's largely accurate but there are
some other details that kind of get left
out of the stuff
so okay now as i said
this is this story has been told and
retold by several
uh you know very famous writers she's
been painted by
uh by very famous people uh
although i should say that the probably
the most famous portrait
of her ostensibly which i think is this
one
oh she was kitty um that may not be her
or it may not have been her painted from
life
now that painting was supposedly painted
by guido rennie
now i'm not entirely sure that that's
her though a lot of people aren't
entirely sure that that's her
um because the thing about gita rennie
was that he didn't start painting
in rome until 1608 and she was executed
in 1599
so he was kind of not really well known
enough uh in 1599 to have been granted
access like to her
prison cell like to paint her you know
what i mean yeah so that might not be
her but a lot of people
when they think of her that's generally
the first portrait that comes up
they're actually not even entirely sure
if guido ren even painted that
um they think that later on uh that his
name might have gotten attached to it to
kind of give it more of like a
okay to make it more famous what you're
saying is is that pop
culture claims that that's her yeah
that's why but it might not be
probably um but it's like i said it's
the most famous like portrait of her and
it's the one that percy shelley saw that
inspired him to like write the uh
poem about her um now she was by all
accounts
a very beautiful young woman um
but i don't know if that was painted
from life it's gonna be like one of
those situations with those roman
emperors i remember reading some really
old books about
rome stuff that was printed in the 30s
and
30s and 40s and they're showing roman
busts and they're claiming
that this one is caesar and this one's
audrey and it's all
[ __ ] up because they weren't they
didn't know they had these busts they
didn't know who they were
that's what i mean there's no way of
knowing really i mean yeah it took time
they ended up
uncovering a damn buried uh theater that
had
busts of some famous uh emperors in it
and underneath the bus
had their names and they went oh they
got they had them switched around
yeah so but and evidently you know those
good
busts that were accurate that's how they
looked yeah you know
they weren't that's how they did look
and you know it's probably a situation
like that these paintings they probably
just old paintings they don't know who
they are
that's hard times it's hard to get a
context that painting in particular they
said if it was
um by guidoranny it might be um
one of the sybils uh which he had done
another painting of that like with the
turban and everything like that that's
in the ufc
but they just they're just saying that
it's it's unlikely that it was
uh beatrice that she was painted from
life
in that portrait you know what i'm
saying on my dad's side of the family
got a whole genealogy and everything
know all the names
one time i was [ __ ] digging through
the damn [ __ ]
old stacks of photos and there's white
people in there i don't even know who
the [ __ ] they are
sometimes it goes back to the [ __ ]
early 1900s [ __ ] late 1800s you know
yeah on antebellum [ __ ] after the after
this after the civil war
there's no there's names there i don't
know who that is
well yeah i mean the thing about it is
like once you go back like past my great
great yeah
it is i don't know who they are anymore
you don't like i knew my
great-grandparents some of them
yeah so even in your own family you
don't know if you're looking at in-laws
cousins direct ancestors to you you
don't know they're just [ __ ] people
it's one of the things like you know i
don't have any children and for a while
they were kind of like [ __ ] with me
like man i don't have any descendants
but then i started doing the math and i
was like well after a couple generations
they're not really related to you anyway
yeah well after a couple generations
everyone's related or you're like it's
just as closely related to like that's
what i was saying
you know you know after about four
generations those descendants
are about as related to you as just some
other [ __ ] walking down
right the street who's the same color of
you it maybe not even that well maybe
not even because there are some people
that are related to you that are in
other races and they're that
they're more closely related to you than
somebody of the same race as you
and that so because it all depends on
what line they came from right not to
say that race isn't a reality there are
some people saying racism
racism right now race is a reality it's
like we even saw it in the army and
medical stuff you know what i mean
[ __ ] you can tell there's different
parameters per race
but what we mean is is that some people
in these other races are a lot more
closely related to you than you think
they are
yeah and i mean it's not as big a deal i
think as people know
and then there's people inside your own
race that are not [ __ ] very related
to you at all
yeah so it's so it's just it's weird
yeah
somebody's asking about uh somebody said
i'd want a painting more like the poster
on the back myself yeah that's uh
yeah the coney and the bar well it's
just called the barbarian first it's
called
it's actually it's not a poster it's
actually on canvas like it's printed on
canvas
yeah that's a frazetta yeah i love frank
was out of focus our friend sophie sent
us yeah
and sophie's gonna come visit next month
she's gonna be here for two weeks
oh she is coming yeah she's coming okay
cool she's gonna fly into sanford
everybody so she'll be a guest on the
show
nice you guys are like so like in a
couple weeks yeah she she's a trip she's
a cutie
you see her is it going to be is it
going to be over my birthday weekend
yes it will we're you know what we're
actually going to be
um well the strange realities conference
which i you know usually play commercial
for
um i think my set is going to be on the
friday night september 25th
i'm not sure exactly what time it might
be like later in the night maybe 9 or 10
p.m
um but the next day the 26th is my
birthday and so we are actually going to
be live streaming an episode
on my birthday okay so yeah we'll have
to have a really good topic for that
i'll have to see what everybody comes up
with on the phone i'm hoping that
florida will lack up on the lockdown so
we can go to [ __ ] mannequins
yeah we might be able to hopefully you
know they're open anyway
you know it's just i [ __ ] hate that
mass [ __ ] if i can i don't know how
strict they are of it
well you just have to wear it like
unless if you're drinking you don't have
to wear it
yeah but you know and you can sit
outside and drink stage it'll cool off a
little bit hopefully too
well not much i don't know about that
but
he's always [ __ ] busting my balls
about [ __ ] temperature i'm like it'll
cool off right she goes no
no i'm like [ __ ] don't tell me that how
long have you tell me we'll [ __ ] cool
off
it's been about over 10 years i just try
to it's my fantasy
yeah and it will cool off but i know
it's not going to [ __ ]
it doesn't usually i mean it might like
sometimes in
october november like sometimes it's
cool
like not cool enough to need a sweater
but like cool enough so that you're not
sweating your balls off
um in the morning and like at night
but you know the daytime is still like
kind of uncomfortable
it's so [ __ ] hot nasty that i haven't
even been riding my motorcycle this
summer
i'm just like [ __ ] i don't blame you i
haven't put all that [ __ ] armor on
and like go out so [ __ ]
fake in the i mean i got [ __ ] three
beautiful motorcycles i [ __ ] never
ride them anymore i got two buells
all custom built [ __ ] abuel got a
[ __ ] 72 [ __ ] honda
honda [ __ ] trail 70 [ __ ] board out
to [ __ ] 140
my dad's old bike got it looks brand new
i should have entered that [ __ ] in a
[ __ ]
i should have entered that [ __ ] into a
[ __ ] contest for [ __ ] custom build
that that bike's a [ __ ]
show bike it's a little bitty show bike
it weighs 50 pounds
and can go almost 70 miles an hour
it's [ __ ] hairy you just pick it up
i'm talking about motorcycles yeah
it's kind of it's it's adorable but it's
kind of terrifying
yeah this is a cute little mini bike
that can go nearly 70.
68 67 and
i got on at front brake one time and did
an endo [ __ ] in the garage and
[ __ ] flip the bike over
i hit the ground first and caught it
like that [ __ ] is
and it didn't get a scratch on it either
well that's good
because you spent a lot of time
restoring it yeah okay all right
so let's travel back in time
to september 9th 1598.
there's this little village called la
petrela de salto
um not that far from rome well 100
kilometers how far is that
that might be far i'm not sure how far
kilometer is
so uh it's kind of it's morning time
hold on sweat beth owens is
asking a question your husband wants to
know what i'm drinking
i'm drinking silver tequila with sam's
sam's brand silver
tequila all right if you want good
[ __ ] silver tequila you get milagro
all right but if you want milagro for
cheaper you get sam's it's that same
[ __ ] thing it's silver malagra i love
[ __ ] malagra
better it's better than uh than uh
[ __ ] uh
jose corvo silver even but it's it's um
sam's silver and uh
rock star
i like that rockstar energy drink yeah
yeah it's good
with tequila with tequila so weird
[ __ ] right
two things i don't like yeah together
yeah it gets you drunk and energetic at
the same time
it's like the speed just what you think
it's like a speed ball of alcoholic
drinks it's the upper and the downer
oh 70 miles 100 kilometers or 70 miles
okay so this was uh
70 miles from rome that's what we're
talking about i didn't have i didn't i
forgot to google it
because usually when i take notes
because i'm using
for most of my notes uh murderpedia has
like several essays about uh beatrice
but um i'm using this one in particular
because i just liked the way it was
written and all the details that it had
and i usually try to
go through there and um you know fix all
the
distances and stuff and you know do
currency exchanges and whatever else i
have to do
but i forgot to do it in this particular
case all right so
uh there's this woman named platilla
calvetti
and uh she was in her house and uh she
heard a commotion
outside like in the morning of september
9th
1598. so she goes out in the street he's
like what's going on
and somebody yells to her they're
screaming in the castle
now the castle was called la rocca
now this was the residence one of the
residences kind of like the summer home
i guess
of um count francesco chenchi
and his family uh this was where he
would go like to get out of rome
when he would get into difficulties
which he often did
because like i said he was a giant
[ __ ] so
um so there's screaming coming from
there now it turned out that uh plotella
calvetti actually
worked in this castle she was like a
housekeeper
type of person which is why everybody
kind of came and said hey somebody's
screaming from there
so um so platilla comes out and uh
she sees that uh she sees
beatrice who at the time even though the
legend says
uh you knew this poor girl was only 16
or 17.
um when they found papers much later on
with uh her birth certificate or her
birth announcement and all this other
stuff it actually turned out she was 22
when her father died so not quite as
young as she'd been portrayed as
so um so platela sees her up there like
at the window looking down
now they say so she comes up to the
crowd and she says what's the matter and
they said francesco
chenchi is dead now
his body is laying in this uh
it was like this bunch of scrub brush
like uh
underneath it was like the castle went
up like that and there was like windows
and then there was like a wooden
balcony type thing so he's down in this
like warren or this like
down in the bushes and there's like kind
of like this small
kind of ragged hole like up in the
wooden balcony so
at first glance it looks like he has
fallen through the balcony
to his death but you know that's
ends up that's not what happened so um
it was about a 40-foot
drop i did remember to look up that
distance he must have weighed enough to
where a 40-foot fall would kill him
no that's not what happened okay because
i'm not sure a 40-foot fall would kill
it wouldn't you no not necessarily but
like i said that's not what happened
maybe bust you up but i don't think it'd
kill you so
they all say get a bunch of ladders
because i guess they couldn't get into
like i'm trying to picture what this
this place is kind of still standing but
it's mostly a ruin it just kind of looks
like a rock outcropping at this point
with just like a little
stone kind of [ __ ] sticking up but so
the guys get the latter and they kind of
climb all over in there
and they make like a stretcher and they
bring the body out now the first thing
one of the first things they notice is
that the body even though
apparently it just fell because they was
just screaming is
um not really all that warm anymore
meaning that the dude's
probably been dead for a while um
yeah so they take him to um
this kind of the pool like on the
grounds and they start washing them
and then they notice that on his
on the side of his head there were uh
three rather significant wounds
uh two of these on the right temple uh
one of which had
completely destroyed his right eye i
believe um and then
a big one that they said was quote
unquote a finger long
now there's they have
actually this is very interesting to me
because apparently they have like a
bunch of witness statements because a
bunch of people like
everybody knew this was like in the
village knew who this was he was really
famous
uh you know in town so it's like when he
died it was like a big deal so like
everybody came running and they wanted
to see what was going on
so there's like tons and tons of witness
statements and i laughed because one of
the witness statements
one of the women that was like helping
to wash the body her name was doritea
and apparently she did not like the dude
so she
kind of thought it was hilarious that he
was dead and apparently a bunch of
witnesses said she was like sticking her
finger in the wind
like hey you're dead kind of thing which
i thought was very funny
so uh yeah so a lot of the other
witnesses were just kind of like
what yeah bro that's a little like
creepy or whatever
now so like i said because the body was
already cold
and because there were these interesting
wounds
on the head um that did not look like
wounds that have been sustained in a
fall i mean this is renaissance era
italy this isn't [ __ ] csi
renaissance or anything like that but
it's was pretty obvious that the dude
was already dead when he fell off quote
unquote fell off the balcony
they also noted that the hole in the
wooden balcony
uh you know landing was not big enough
to have accommodated him because he was
apparently kind of a big dude
okay hold on this [ __ ] we gotta sort out
okay okay let me see
first of all louie's asked me lou
hernandez asked me if i've ever had
trace generators sony's
tequila no i never had that one you can
send it to me
uh let's see what else that's how i'm
gonna get free
all right um then um let me see
um dj maniac said you got his piston
shirt
and thank you all right yeah we sent
those out yeah
well we've been sending them out in
waves yeah
um graham townsend says what the [ __ ]
a foot
in meters all right man a foot is 12
inches long
it's about like that there's about three
feet in the meter
yeah rough okay roughly three feet in a
meter so what 40 feet
is about what 40 feet is probably about
what six meters
yeah six or seven six centimeters about
that yeah
it's you know two stories about two
stories yeah
i know sorry but maybe not from i
learned the metric system at school but
i don't remember it
the metric system is too effeminate for
america
[Laughter]
he's so like he's so like obsessed with
stuff being a feminist yeah it's all
it's all about machismo
okay like for like here's an example
fahrenheit all right
you guys will use these [ __ ]
effeminate celsius and [ __ ] where
things freeze at zero no [ __ ] all that
okay
we just want random numbers
fahrenheit is based upon the [ __ ]
temperature of
human blood yeah okay that's the
standard
how hot is human blood it's like alchemy
man
yeah yeah it's alchemy is what we're
talking about here and that's the way
we're gonna keep it
and that's what sends [ __ ] to
the moon
okay that [ __ ] wasn't done in the metric
system it was done in [ __ ]
alchemy except for that one except for
that one mission where they were
supposed to send something to mars or
something and they missed because they
forgot to do the conversion they didn't
do the conversion right like yeah but
that wasn't our fault it was their fault
they gave us some [ __ ] remember when
that was your measurement system
okay this is the american imperial
system it's a [ __ ]
empire a empire the empire
of america america
that's how you say it go ahead dj maniac
said the the ticker is new it's actually
not
i actually started doing a long time ago
but i just kept forgetting to put it on
so
because i'm an idiot alex laughing that
i said this elsa was a family
i have it's all soft soft
feminine sophisticated european [ __ ] man
that's just
no no no no america's not like that
we're just a bunch of dummies
it's like no america is like the klingon
empire
yeah or something yeah i don't want to i
don't want that for it it's a cross
between
the klingon empire and idiocracy if you
ever seen that movie so they got some of
that in it too
but that's our superpower you can't
reason with us
it's just not going to work yeah because
we're idiots
we're not reasonable dj maniac also said
i'd watch the [ __ ] out of csi
renaissance as would i
yeah somebody really needs to make
putting leeches on people right
i love it but yeah so they they weren't
completely
stupid they were like look the the
hole's too small the dude's body's
already cold these head wounds clearly
um came from something other than a fall
and also they noticed that he had like
this really interesting bruise on his
wrist that looks like maybe somebody had
been like holding him down or fighting
with them
also they thought that the wounds in his
head looked like they'd been made with
something like
a hatchet or a pointed iron whatever the
hell that is
so i guess it's like some kind of you
know like an iron spike or some [ __ ]
like that i don't know
so uh yeah so see they're saying
tom the imperial that system is a
british system and we have moved on
no you guys bent a knee you took the
knee
and [ __ ] gave up your traditions
and your science that was british
science okay
[ __ ] all this other people's sciences
british science
kind of like how sometimes men have
science where it's just a science for
men
just you know it's called man it's
called bro science
all right it's in every [ __ ] gym out
there it's about how many ro how much
roids to take
it's called bro science uh oh what's up
pokey pokey has arrived
so it's i forgot where i was going with
this [ __ ] cat comes in
good girl pookie
don't worry about all these [ __ ]
measurements everything all right
let us handle this we know what we're
doing we're american
i don't think you should let us handle
anything no no
oh the reason why this [ __ ] exists is
because we have a lot of machines here
that are in that [ __ ]
in all that system and we have all the
tools to do it
and so to [ __ ] make full conversions
it is slightly kind of being weeded out
over time
but some of these machines are old and
they're still working and you have to
use all that stuff
and then sometimes it's just a thing of
arrogance it's like [ __ ] you we don't
want y'all [ __ ] foreigners working on
our
[ __ ] so we're gonna make it with tools
you guys can't even [ __ ] work with
that's another thing you know it's an
entire country fueled by spite
yeah spite is part of it it's like
spite and immaturity whatever you call
it whatever
you call it whatever you label it and
you call it what it
call it whatever you want i'm calling it
what it is there's something about
working on an american car working on
american motorcycle and it's all [ __ ]
american standard tools
you know what i mean it's just there's
just something about it america
yeah the british were doing that too you
know they had their own [ __ ]
system we all got our own system
yeah so okay uh another thing that when
they
uh investigated and they went inside the
castle to check out the crime scene
like i said csi renaissance
they also found that the the uh counts
bed sheets were all covered with
blood like someone had killed him in the
bed and then pulled him out of bed and
dumped him
so not master criminals we're not
talking about master crimes they're
making it up as they were going along
well yeah pretty much i mean they you
know it wasn't like a plan
so uh it came to pass
like after they started questioning all
the witnesses they started questioning
like
you know people that want them dead
which is pretty much everybody
they discovered that what the plan
was was that
beatrice who like i said was 22 at the
time she was the daughter
uh francesco chenchi's second wife
lucrezia
um and there was another son
named giacomo now he he supposedly knew
about the plot but was not
in town at the time but like i said he
did know about it and i think he knew
what was going down
there was also another guy named olympia
calvaty who was the like the manager of
the castle he was also
the husband of the first woman that
heard the screaming it was the
housekeeper
he was supposedly also beatrice's lover
uh she may have seduced him into the
plot into killing
uh the dad and then there was another
guy like there was another conspirator
that they actually just paid like
essentially a hitman
so what they think happened was that the
two hitmen olympio and the other guys
think his name was marzio
they basically drugged francesco chanchi
um and i don't know if they
drugged him like to poison him or if
they just drugged him like to make him
easier to manage
i'm not really sure but it turned out
that whatever it was the drug didn't
work like it didn't put him entirely to
sleep and he ended up waking up
so the two guys go into his bed chambers
and they they either bashed in his head
with a hammer
or they took like an iron spike and
hammered it into his head
until he was dead and then they threw
him over the balcony
um and put a hole in the balcony and the
wooden balcony to make it look like an
accident obviously they didn't do that
good job of it
um and as i said the bruise that they
found on his arm was uh indeed from them
holding him down while they were
killing him so it was like this big
[ __ ] mess
now the reason that and here's the thing
when the conspirators were arrested
nobody was really
nobody really thought they should get in
trouble like everyone was kind of like
yeah
the dude got murdered but he kind of had
it coming
like you know what i mean like i feel
like everybody knew about because here's
the
thing francesco
was well known for i mean he had a lot
of money he was a wealthy
nobleman he had gotten into a lot of
trouble
even by the standards of the day um and
had been able to weasel his way out of
it
by paying barry's people off like paying
fines and [ __ ] like that
um he had gotten in trouble for uh he
had
i'm not sure entirely what this is but
he had gotten in trouble for
he had a mistress obviously um
and he made her like
do various sexual things i'm guessing
butt stuff
um damn and well i'm just saying like
from from the way that they
like and then he got arrested and like
the charge is like
un unsavory vice or unnecessary
like it sounds like butt stuff for all
you know though
with the mentality of the time it might
have just been something like
real [ __ ] mild like [ __ ] oral it
could have been [ __ ]
teddy [ __ ] or some stupid [ __ ] like
that those [ __ ] had a weird
attitude so
there was a situation like this this is
coming to mind
i think somebody in the audience might
know what case i'm talking about i
thought it was in the south there was a
dude
who was probably like one of the biggest
[ __ ] known to man
in this small town and he was abusing a
lot of people and talking lots of [ __ ]
and [ __ ] with people's women and
beating people up and one of these days
the whole town just conspired to murder
him i know exactly who that is
yeah ken rex mcelroy okay yeah i wrote
about him in my book yeah
they murdered his ass and something in
broad daylight in the middle of the
street
in the middle of the street that's right
then they shoot him yeah and
i think people were charged weren't they
but no no no one was charged no
conviction because no one would admit
anything yeah that's right
and the whole town like saw [ __ ] [ __ ]
around and find out
[ __ ] around and find out seriously that
dude was
a [ __ ] dick this is [ __ ] america
you [ __ ] around and find out what
happened
i think it was in missouri yeah or
something it was it was a long time ago
it was actually like in the 50s or
something like that
these little towns you know like [ __ ]
where my dad was from like
[ __ ] [ __ ] heidelberg mississippi
and [ __ ] if
if you get enough enemies in that town
you're dead meat
but they almost always [ __ ] get the
right man though they know who they're
dealing with
just relax leave it up to them they know
what's up yeah victor garcia said the
documentary skidmore is about that's
right skidmore missouri that's what it
was
yeah i wrote about it in my book he was
just i mean he really
yeah he seemed to like revel in just
being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
to the people and that's only one that
was only one egregious example there's a
lot to that
it's just that that was one of the cases
that came up there's lots of that [ __ ]
that's happened
yeah i just don't think it was
necessarily in broad daylight the whole
town in on it
more like in kind of secret nobody liked
the dude and a few dudes took care of it
i don't think that happened
but how it ended up happening it was in
broad daylight it was the middle of the
day um
apparently a whole bunch of people had
gathered like at the town
center or whatever and they said the
sheriff's like look you're gonna do
something about this dude it's like you
know he's done this that the other thing
he shot a guy
it's like you know this old store grocer
guy and yeah he was just like this real
like giant [ __ ] and he he kind of
like reveled in going around the town
going i can do whatever i want but yeah
you know
and he never got in trouble because he
would intimidate
like anybody that would um you know that
would stand up in court against him so
he always ended up getting let
go so basically the sheriff was like
well look um i can't do anything but
uh i'm gonna go out of town for a little
while wink wink yeah and you guys take
care of that
and then yeah and then they said oh and
by the way him and his girlfriend are
over at the bar
if you want to like do something about
that so yeah it's like he so he
had been in the bar drinking it was just
like afternoon i think and he just got
in the truck and like somebody just
[ __ ] shot him
from the street and nobody would say
peep nobody has said anything to this
day nobody
would give up the person that it was
because everybody's mom says
everybody hated that guy oracle mom says
um the old saying goes in texas
he needed killing and let me tell you
something
that's not just texas my dad has
actually used that [ __ ] phrase from
mississippi that was quite common
he needed killing yeah and that's just
for some of you foreigners up there in
these foreign savage
lands they don't understand how certain
[ __ ] happens on the small town level
especially
in some of these in these rural areas
you know down south and [ __ ]
every now and then a [ __ ] needs
killing and they take care of it
that was an example well see i think
that the reason that the
case of bianca duchenchi has like
survived and was like so you know taken
up by all these artists and stuff like
that was because
her dad francesco chenchi he wasn't just
[ __ ] her over he was [ __ ] a lot of
people over
everybody hated the dude and he was
definitely somebody that needed killing
and so they kind of nutted up and did it
and then they got executed in horrible
ways so i think it was like a big
injustice
because the whole like point of a lot of
the plays and stuff and operas and
[ __ ] that had been written about her was
that you know the difference between
the you know the regular law and like
the moral law like she was probably in
the right because
he was a terrible person and she took
him out hajiki's a good name says hey a
long time listener first time
commenter love your podcast thank you
very much thank you
and then good name i'm just gonna call
you good name i can't pronounce that
first part
all right
[Laughter]
going through the thing go ahead yeah so
uh where was i oh yeah so
other than like him having a mistress
and doing weird [ __ ] with her like
that's not even like unusual by any
standards however he also got in trouble
for
molesting young boys on several
occasions
and um he also beat his wife and
daughter
uh starved his servants did other things
there are um
part of the legend is that he uh was
raping his daughter i'm not sure if
that's true or not but even if it wasn't
um he's still not
he was still eligible he was still yeah
um
some of them alex rivera said um
this reminds me i looked up the inbred
family tom was talking about that was
awful you thought [ __ ] was [ __ ] up
wasn't it
that boy [ __ ] that dude barking like
a dog
and then you goadie pointing to the
ground where his [ __ ] brother was
buried that's [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
go on youtube and look up inbred family
[ __ ] yeah it's up down up in the up in
the [ __ ] appalachian mountains
[ __ ] several generations that
of inbred people god it's bad
yeah it's like the hills have eyes um
yeah so one thing like according to a
lot of the
servants that were at this house because
this um castle in particular la roca
this was not their
regular house this was like i said this
was their summer house
and there are actually um it's suspected
that he was keeping his second wife
lucrezia his daughter
uh beatrice and their uh the youngest
son who's i think his name was bernardo
or something like that i have to like
look it up in my notes he was only 12 or
13.
that he was keeping them essentially
prisoners there for whatever reason
um they think that it might have been
either because one of his oldest
daughters um essentially tried to sue
for
emancipation she wanted to marry without
his
permission but still get a dowry and the
courts agreed with her
um and so he was mad about that or it
might have been
uh that beatrice had gotten pregnant
by uh her lover who was one of the
conspirators to kill him
and uh so he might have you know he
might have been pissed off about that
so one of the things that really stuck
with me that the servant said that he
would do
was that he would walk around this house
and like i said he's keeping
his wife his daughter who's 22 and his
12 13 year old son essentially prisoners
in this house like he won't really let
them leave and [ __ ]
so one thing that he would do he had
something that was like scabies or mange
or something like that
and she he would make his daughter
essentially scratch his balls like you
know
with a stick and stuff like that also
one um
the the servant said that he would walk
around just like in his shirt and like
short like undershorts or whatever and
if he had to piss
or [ __ ] like his daughter had to like
bring the [ __ ] bucket and like
sit there with it like while he was like
he was making them do that
and he would whip them and like do all
kind of so like i said he was a piece of
[ __ ] i mean everybody
everybody hated the dude i mean you can
see that like
when he got killed like even that woman
that was washing his body was like
laughing at him and sticking her [ __ ]
finger in the wound because she was like
hey you're dead kind of thing
so it's like everybody hated the
[ __ ] he was just well known
for being a terrible person that never
got in trouble because he had money
you know what i mean yeah there's no
dude just like this you know that famous
painting of that [ __ ] dude
in the [ __ ] 70 hundreds outfits like
that and you know he's pointing at
pointing at the [ __ ] painter and he's
[ __ ] smiling and you know
and he usually writes some funny meme
caption yeah yeah what's that guy's name
do you remember that guy's name i can't
remember offhand
anyway it's a famous meme you'll see it
you know where he's [ __ ] pointing at
you and smiling
that dude was a [ __ ] [ __ ] when i
first saw that i thought maybe he'd be
[ __ ] funny and cool
nah [ __ ] was a serial rapist he
raped
men and women that worked for him he did
all kinds of [ __ ] weird he was like
this dude
like that exactly like the dude she's
talking about he was like that yeah
and he when he died everybody breathed a
sigh of relief they hated him
yeah it's like you know please try it in
your life just try to be
don't don't be the person that when you
die everybody's like shoot good riddance
to them but they had all this [ __ ]
rank and they could [ __ ] abuse people
well they knew nothing would happen to
them nothing would happen to them they
didn't really live in a world where
people broke the rules and whip somebody
or murdered somebody you know what i
mean to [ __ ] restore justice they
didn't have batman
that's what it is they didn't have
batman back in those days
well yeah but i mean essentially in the
in these days yeah i mean francesco
chenchi
he you know not only like he had two
sons that were older i think they
uh were just as like kind of [ __ ]
like he was they both got killed in
duels like before this happened
like i said he had another daughter that
was just like [ __ ] you i'm out of here
um so it wasn't just like them it wasn't
them just imagining it
batman hold on batman did not appear
until the french and the american
revolutions that's when batman
and they were out of control but that's
when that [ __ ] started
that's when these dudes [ __ ] got
their issue
yeah well like i said yeah i i think
that might be
another thing that contributes to
uh to beatrice acenci's ongoing uh
legend is that she basically even though
she was only 22 years old this pretty
young girl
and she was basically like look my dudes
you know my dad's
an [ __ ] and i'm gonna do something
about it and she actually got
i mean her stepmom was involved too
because she also hated the dude now she
was the one that came up with the poison
yeah uh to kill him and it didn't kill
him and that's why they ended up having
what year was this again
1598. he was killed are you not talking
about societies that have equal
representation
you know what i mean under the law that
was the [ __ ] problem and that's
really what caused all the revolutions
that
gave birth to the modern world
if you were part of the aristocracy you
were a high-ranking male you could do
whatever you wanted as long as it was
a person that was lesser than you yeah
in the hierarchy yep
you know uh later on we came up with a
concept of [ __ ]
equal representation of the law where
everyone had access to the [ __ ] legal
system
so and that took a while for that [ __ ]
to be sorted out
and um it wasn't really fully sorted out
here in the united states
really you could say to the 60s and even
sometimes now later
still not because yeah it's a constant
[ __ ] battle if you
have money i mean obviously you can get
away with [ __ ] i mean if you're poor
you're going to that's another thing you
know i hate to tell you yeah if
if you're rich even here in the united
states you can do whatever you want
you can get away with anything yeah so
it hasn't really buy your way around it
i mean
at least nowadays people know i think i
think back then
it was like more widespread just because
it wasn't as
if you didn't hear about it as much and
it wasn't as
sanctioned i guess if you're one of
these [ __ ] ultra
rich and powerful and dirty child
island men who did not [ __ ] kill
themselves if you're like one of these
they're doing [ __ ] that was happening in
the [ __ ] renaissance in the middle
ages
medieval period even back to the roman
period i see that [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
little st
james island that just reminds me of the
[ __ ] island of [ __ ] capri and [ __ ]
with [ __ ] uncle nero and [ __ ]
running around with his little fishes
his little [ __ ] little kids and [ __ ]
and throwing them up you know what i
mean doesn't that doesn't that remind
you of that
yeah just roman sex islands and [ __ ] is
what it reminds me of
it's bizarre i couldn't believe that
that [ __ ] was really going on
yep it makes you wonder how much more of
it there is
yeah i mean like i said bad shit's
probably more widespread than you think
but
maybe not as widespread as you think if
you're like really pessimistic
well i'm not trying to imagine more of
it i'm just wondering how much more of
it there is
yeah you know what i mean i bet you
there's a lot more yeah maybe
and there's no telling what's going on
inside you know growing up in brazil
seeing that [ __ ] and growing up in
brazil makes me wonder what it's
actually what's actually going on in
[ __ ] places like brazil
south america because it'd be easy even
easier to get away with it there
yeah yeah well and people are going to
go where it's easier to get away with
[ __ ]
yeah nobody wants you don't walk across
yet
she'll walk right across the keyboard
well she doesn't know she's like i don't
know what's wrong with you i know those
little software and it's like neat
little
she actually when i had that one open
the other day she was trying to pull the
buttons off she was like putting her
little paw underneath and going
yeah why is that there she's like what
is this yeah she's very curious
she's fascinated you know what else
she's fascinated she's fascinated by
that little piece of tape that you put
over your like
yeah over there with the camera like on
the tablet
any piece of tape she's gonna try to
pull it off yeah for some reason she's
like really fast she can't have tape
i ought to just start sticking tape on
things so she can pull tape off
yeah but she'd be super into that she'd
be super late yeah i'll pull the tape
out i told him i said what don't we have
like a
like an old broken tablet that you can
just stick tape on so she can just pull
it off
she loves what's this tape dude
i don't know why she's so fascinated
with that tape but yeah so
so obviously since this uh you know
wasn't the most um
expertly handled crime in the world but
you know you gotta give him props they
did kill the dude right
but they got caught pretty much
immediately so as i said it turned out
that lucrezia the
the mom um her stepmom rather she had
she was the one that had made uh the
poison
and uh they had essentially hired two
hitmen
uh olympio calventi who was uh the
castle manager like i said
and this other guy marcio catalano who
they had just given money to to like
help out with the [ __ ]
and uh beatrice was also in on it and um
according to most witnesses she was kind
of the one where because i guess the
hitmen
when they initially went in there and
like the poison wasn't working and the
dude was waking up and they were like oh
[ __ ] let's like abort abort
um she was like no man do it you know
what i mean so they
so apparently she was the one that kind
of like you know
girded their loins i guess and like got
them to go through with it when
apparently they didn't really want to
say that
she's like where are we going where are
we going so um so they all get arrested
all the family get arrested
um they also arrested giacomo who was
the brother um i believe he was older
was he older than her or it's i don't
know but his he was the brother
even though he was out of town they did
determine that he was in on it and he
confessed even though the confession was
under tortures a lot of things were uh
even
at this even in this time period so
i don't know how accurate they are but
uh they did torture all of them and all
the confessions came to light it should
be noted though
that uh beatrice would not
confess even under torture she kept
saying that she was innocent and that it
was an accident
and she would not give it up no matter
what they said
so uh the judicial process
takes about a year um now
the two hitmen subsequently uh died
before they could be essentially like
brought to trial or whatever
uh olympio calvetti who was uh beatrice
gentry's lover
uh he had taken off and like gone into
hiding however uh
he was found by a bounty hunter who
killed him with a hatchet like cut his
head off um
now marzio catalano the other hitman the
one that they had hired
um they actually uh put him in a prison
and tortured him
for uh confession and he actually died
undergoing
torture so both of the people that had
actually killed the dude
um you know died before the big
trial could take place now
10th of september 1599
was execution day so they lead
giacomo beatrice and lucrezia
um out on the thing like so the two
women
are like walking they have like their
morning clothes on or whatever and they
let them walk they didn't have any like
ropes or they weren't tied up or
anything like that
giacomo however they put on a cart
and they were pretty much like torturing
him the whole way
like to the execution place
which it was like an execution parade i
guess which is pretty [ __ ] up
but that's what they were doing they
were just like torturing him the whole
time
uh so this happened at a place called
castle saint angelo which is on the
banks of the tiber river
so yeah so they have the cart they have
the two women they're going to
uh the place now giacomo even though he
wasn't even
at the house when his dad was killed he
didn't know about it
or so he said like under torture but
they decided they were going to execute
him anyway now him being a man
they decided they were gonna make an
example of him
so they basically while he's going
through the streets on a cart
they're like tearing his pieces of his
flesh off with like heated
pinchers uh they put him up on the block
and smash in his head
with a sledge hammer and then draw and
quarter him
and then like kind of hang the pieces up
for everybody
yeah after the [ __ ] blow well i hope
so i'm not really entirely sure i mean
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] up right
holy crap that was justice back in those
days i guess
now it should be noted that even though
like a lot of the common people of rome
like when
um the death sentences for the family
came out
like a lot of the common people like hey
man it's like you know francesco chanchi
was like
it was a [ __ ] douche it's like why
are you yeah like we're glad he's dead
don't worry about it yeah be reasonable
but um yeah that's what everybody said
like you know everybody kind of rallied
to their cause
however it turned out that uh old
pope clement viii there had been
i guess shortly before this there had
been another case
of um i believe it was a son that had
poisoned his mother
or killed his mother like to get his
inheritance or whatever
so the pope didn't want there to be he
thought
that oh now there'll be like this big
rash of like familial killings
of patricide of stuff like that so he
wanted to make an example of these
people to like stop it
even though like which is dumb it
doesn't work no it doesn't work
it's well that's why it's dumb right
it's d and also it's dumb because they
were obviously mitigating circumstances
and everybody knew it
right so it just seemed like so the pope
was just being a real [ __ ] [ __ ] stick
in this i have to say
i mean you know but but you know he was
saying there had been another
occasion for money so the church had a
[ __ ]
the church had a difficult job they're
trying to keep order in the [ __ ]
basically lawless society of
a bunch of people that were this
admitted man it was kind of savage times
so they're trying to set some kind of an
example
you could really only rule those people
by fear
if you like that book you're talking
about if you kind of research the way
those societies operated they were they
were tough you know what i mean yeah
they were you couldn't deal with the
average person you had to [ __ ] use
some kind of fear to keep them in check
i mean you had intelligent people
but a lot of them weren't intelligent
it's like anything else what was that
book about the better [ __ ] angels of
our nature and [ __ ] like
stephen pinker yeah that's
so i can kind of understand that the
church had a very difficult job they're
trying to keep order out of a bunch of a
bunch of disorderly people
there's no way to [ __ ] have a uniform
application of the law
no professional police no professional
investigative [ __ ]
abilities you know what i mean no no
forensic csi
[ __ ] you know no real court system
it was everything was done by
intimidation you know what i mean
well that's the thing you could do you
could do some [ __ ] like i mean and even
in this time period you could
still do some [ __ ] like happened in the
salem witch trials where you could
basically just come into a court and go
hey there's ghosts flying around the
courtroom and they said that she did it
nobody's like oh i suppose
yeah so what are you gonna do you can't
fight against that can you
so on an individual level yeah he [ __ ]
these individuals over
ought to let him go but i also
understand that they would have lost
control
but i mean that's what everybody said
that they should be let go yeah i mean
so it wasn't just kind of thing where
if i was a pope i would have had a
difference i would had i would have had
a third option i would have punished him
but it would have been a lesser
punishment that's what i would have done
that seemed like the better way to go
about it they didn't think they didn't
think that way back then they were very
extreme
there was they either [ __ ] you up or
they let you go there wasn't anything in
between that was kind of
the trend i mean sometimes they made
exceptions that's what i would have done
i would have just said i would have come
out as the pope
and be like hey that wasn't going to say
yeah we're going to have to put them in
service to the church for about five
years
that's what i'd have done they had to
pay penance
and then you know you bring him into a
convent for a couple years and then let
him go something like that
because like i said i think everyone
would have been happy i mean the case
that he was
used that he was thinking about that
he's like oh i don't want to set another
president like that
that was a case that seemed i couldn't
find a lot of information on it
because apparently it was so common that
it's like nobody even remembers much
about it anymore
but apparently that was pretty much just
done for like
financial reasons like the sun just like
off in his mom who was a countess or
something like that
just to like get his inheritance early
or whatever
so i i don't feel like there were any
mitigating circumstances
in that case from what i could determine
so
it seems like it was a really different
case i mean this was a case where
obviously this dude was despised even at
the time
where dudes could get away with a lot
more [ __ ] everybody hated him and talked
about what a [ __ ] he was
and how abusive he was and no one was
sad that he was dead not a single
[ __ ] person
and everybody it seemed like everybody
was like rallying to the causes like
don't
execute them it's like you know we you
know no one's sorry the dude's dead it's
like he's dead good
it's like life goes on um
so everybody was like kind of upset
about it and i think it helped
too let's be honest that um
beatrice was 22 and was probably pretty
hot
yeah i mean if she'd been like an ugly
hag
i don't think she would have gotten
doing it she would she wouldn't have
gotten as much support and that's just
the truth of the matter looks are looks
are very important perception is reality
a lot of people
yeah the optics of that because she
looked like this innocent young girl
it's like look at the dad's been doing
this because he did shitty stuff to all
of his kids and his wives and
like people his servants and like other
people so it wasn't just her
but i do feel like the fact
that the legend grew around her ins in
particular
right um was for that reason and also
because there were
there were um what the [ __ ] luke what is
she doing
pawn on a book come here no and also
that there were that there were whiffs
that
um he was raping her there was incest
and that she was trying to quote unquote
defend her honor or
probably was so he might have been i'm
not really sure
but um i do think that that might that
that might
um sorry it's very distracting yeah
she's gonna tear [ __ ] up what are you
doing
she feels neglected so she's trying to
get attention okay
we love you it's okay she's purring
oh she got what she wanted you wanted
attention didn't you yeah
i wanted to change it oh poor pokey yeah
yeah
so um so giacomo gets all this
he gets all [ __ ] up like drawn and
quartered and everything like that
and if you go to like there's a museum i
guess um
i saw it on atlas obscura i think um and
there's like a display that's about
about her and about like the execution
and everything and they even made like a
little diorama
of like this little naked man being like
drawn a corner and i'm like okay
and they even have the sword there that
they like [ __ ] it's like [ __ ] up
but yeah so so all that [ __ ] happened to
him
and then uh lucrezia the mom and
beatrice were beheaded with a sword now
apparently lucrezia was
she fainted before she got beheaded
which was probably a mercy
um i love i don't love because this is
kind of [ __ ] up
but apparently one of the newspapers or
one of the public things about the
execution at the time
said that lucretia lucretia had um a
hard time like
settling her head onto the beheading
block because of her boobs were too big
i wonder if it was true i don't know i
don't know if they just said that or if
that was just something i said like
salacious little detail they weren't
sounds like fake news i'm like that's
dude she was gorgeous they were gonna
behead that chick
they were gonna be had that chick as
fine as she was
over her bad dad who was doing this and
that well this was the mop this was the
step
oh okay
she put it up there and then things are
so giant it's like a pillow
you know and she i can imagine she
couldn't even put her head on
her head on it people have not changed
yeah not one bit
but yeah although they're probably
trying to make it sound salacious and
what it really was is that she was
extremely obese
yeah i don't know i i don't um i don't
see a lot of descriptions of lucretia
even though she like got [ __ ] over by
the dude as well like apparently he beat
her up and all this other kind of [ __ ]
too
but i guess since she wasn't as young
and pretty as the daughter
i think the rush nobody hears about her
i think the rationale
is that they didn't want people going
out killing their dads because he was an
[ __ ]
and what they wanted because there'd be
a whole rash because like watching that
yeah and then and i think what the
message was supposed to be was
if you got a problem with your dad doing
this [ __ ] come to us to church and we'll
handle it
that's probably what the message was
except they wouldn't
how the hell are they going to handle
they would have handled they're not
going to do anything they would have
handled it in the way the church would
have handled it they would have got the
guy
you stop what you're doing you need to
pay penance we want [ __ ] 5 000 gold
pieces or you're going to [ __ ] it and
he's like okay here and then
yeah yeah that's what would happen so
what happened like i said that's
there is something to be said for
beatrice just being like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i'm almost like i'm tired of this
[ __ ]
let's [ __ ] stab the dude and throw
him off the [ __ ] balcony and she did
it they didn't plan it right
no they probably could have played it a
little bit better i gotta say because
they get caught pretty much immediately
it must have been done
she's 22. it's done in the heat of the
moment it was done in the heat of the
moment it might have been
i mean it was more like a manslaughter
yeah i don't know like i'm sure that
they had talked about it prior to that
but because there were like five
conspirators involved but i don't know
if they were planning on doing it that
particular day maybe it was just kind of
like that day they're like oh this seems
like a good day let's do it
yeah you know what i mean and then
they're like we're not ready and then
they just did it anyway and they kind of
[ __ ] it they're all in there talking
about cats will not be ignored and pooka
doesn't understand
cookie doesn't understand the internet
no she doesn't she doesn't
she's like why are you guys just sitting
here talking to the light box and not
like
they don't know what yeah this is just a
light box why are you talking to a light
box the light box doesn't do anything
i'm over here let's play like the light
box isn't as cute as me
yeah there's no concept of people of
other
thousands of people watching there's no
that's that's not in a cat yeah she's
smart but she's not that
she's not that smart cats don't know
what the internet is she thinks we're
just talking to each other looking at
lights
yeah which i would imagine that looks
crazy as [ __ ]
yeah she probably she's like they're
[ __ ] crazy
she's like i've been looking at those
lights all day and it's like they're not
petting me they're not like
walking they're not playing with me in
the closet i don't understand
but yeah so so they cut the creature's
head off and they cut
beatrice's head off um and again
do you want a drink oh yeah i'm gonna
get you some of that tea
okay we'll see if that's any good see if
it's any good because i'm out of orange
juice so
i didn't know i had to go get orange
juice today i forgot all about it
but yeah uh but yeah to give beatrice to
her
props she not only didn't confess
anything under torture
she also just like went to the
went to the chop and blocked like a g
and let him cut her head off
so you know now pretty much as
soon as the execution happened like i
said she had a lot of
um you know the public was on their side
you know in their favor because
everybody hated that dude so i think
that kind of
had to do with why her her case in
particular has like
endured i guess when maybe some other
people haven't
although i should say that i mean the
case
in italy particularly uh was well known
from then but i think there was this one
particular
book um and it was written by this
historian
named ludovico antonio
and he wrote essentially like a you know
history of italy or something like that
and um he wrote it in the 1740s
and in that book it seems like
a lot of the threads of
the stuff that would become the legend
about her were kind of planted
and they think that percy shelley
actually
read this book and
between that book and between the
supposedly
guido rennie painted portrait of her um
that that was what inspired him to write
his poem about her which is just called
the chenji
um which like i said was the inspiration
for many other
things subsequently so
it does seem like okay so
the thing about it though is that one of
the main
aspects of the legend
is the whole um incest
thing now it should be noted
that during the trial
um beatrice never said
that her dad had raped her or was
uh you know engaging in incest or
anything like that she didn't really say
that
until the end
and they think that it might have been
her lawyer's attempt to try to
you know get a lighter sentence or
something like that and they didn't even
say i believe it was lucretia that said
she didn't even say
that that francesco
had raped her but that he had threatened
to or that he was going to or the way
she worded it was kind of strange
so it almost seemed like it that it
hadn't happened but it was going to
happen or he had threatened to do it
um which like i said it's still that's
not good that doesn't
you know but um you know and i'm not
saying that
that because he didn't do that that all
the other [ __ ] that he did wasn't bad
enough for her to want to kill him
because it totally was
but i'm just saying that that's become
like such a an integral
an integral part of the legend about her
like the whole incest thing and she was
defending her honor and
stuff like that and also that she was a
teenager when she was actually
somewhat older um and they're not sure
entirely thank you if that happened
i thought it was good
oh yeah nice huh that is actually very
good yeah
it'll be uh gingery
but yeah so so it wasn't really
mentioned until the end now
they did have some witness testimony at
the trial from some of the other
servants in the house
that said that they remembered at least
one night when
lucretia the wife had been quote unquote
kicked out of the bedroom
and that beatrice
later said to the servant that her dad
had come into her bed
and she had like told him she didn't
want him in there so i don't know
if that means that he was doing that or
if he had threatened her or whatever but
like i said it's not good either way
but it was just like a little more gray
than has been previously said also
um there is some there's an interesting
thing
that they found out when somebody
like a historian went digging through
and found like her
will um she had actually been allowed to
make a will like a few days before
she was executed and she left like a
whole bunch of money to various
charities and churches and stuff like
that
she also left kind of a mysterious
amount to a friend of hers
as alms quote unquote to take care of a
poor boy
um she's like and essentially she said
you know
i told you about that [ __ ] verbally you
know and if she dies then you know give
it to somebody else to take care of this
person
now they're speculating that she might
have had an
illegitimate son sounds like it which
might have been the reason
one of the reasons why her dad was mad
and essentially imprisoned her
at la roca um
they're not entirely sure but that seems
to be the most
reasonable because she was having an
affair
with olympio calvetti one of the um
he was the castle manager and one of the
conspirators like one of the guys that
had killed her
killed the dad so uh who
whose wife was also like the housekeeper
but yeah she was all she was like
happening
so yeah so there's the speculation is
that she had had a son with him
and uh her dad had like taken her and
had like secreted her away at larocca
because of that because the pregnancy
because the shame and all that kind of
crap
and um you know so that's what i don't
know who with the dad
who the father was maybe not although it
seemed like all the servants
knew that the two of them had a thing
right so maybe they weren't like keeping
it as secret as they thought they were
you know what i'm saying i don't know if
the wife knew or not maybe she didn't
give a [ __ ]
i'm not sure all right everybody hit
that like button please hit that thumbs
up
hit that thumbs up button yeah but it's
interesting that
so like i said i feel like a lot of her
enduring legend
of you know her being like a virginal
teenager which
she wasn't she was a little bit older
and probably not virginal but like i
said it doesn't
that doesn't make it any less horrible
like what ended up happening to her it's
like you know
should she have killed her dad yeah
probably wasn't the best idea
but you can't really blame her i mean
well there wasn't any kind of law or
laughter
yeah what else was she gonna do there
was no equal representation under the
law
no equal defense under the law under
those particular
circumstances i would have [ __ ] off
that [ __ ] i would have too
because he's imposing upon the human
rights of others
that's what i mean no recourse through
the law to take care of that so what you
do is you knock that [ __ ] off
and that's why a lot of bad [ __ ]
happened during that era
that's the law even though it doesn't
work all the time
was a way to ameliorate all this [ __ ]
yeah but even to today here in the
united states
you have some people that are so good at
the law that they can circumvent it and
commit crimes at the same time
you have to have you have to have batman
there sometimes to go
look and like that guy like the cop in
that town there's
this guy is circumventing the law and
breaking the laws at the same time
we know who he is he's a danger to the
community well and they couldn't hold
him on
anything because everyone was afraid to
testify against him
so in a case like that where everybody
knows what's going on it's a small
community
vigilante justice happens and is that
the right thing to do not legally
morally though it might be
just because it's legally incorrect
doesn't mean i
feel like that was the case here and i
feel like a lot of the subsequent stuff
that's been written about her
um you know all the plays and operas and
stuff have focused on that very theme
and she even says that like in um in one
of the plays i think it was uh alberto
moravia he wrote a play about her
in the 50s and that was one of her
quotes was that
as i'm paraphrasing but essentially um
you know your law says that i did it but
i have a higher law and it's like you
know what i mean you can't convict me on
that because
she was morally correct because
theoretically she took him out
theoretically laws are supposed to be
moral but we know that lawmakers are
politicians and how much morality are
you
you
really [ __ ] how much morality are you
really gonna get out of a [ __ ] lawyer
or a politician about one of the same
here
not much in general there's not much
they don't have a good track record
they're like everybody else you know
they have the same inclinations as
everybody else
and here in the united states the lawyer
class really is the new priest class
and they do a lot of the same [ __ ] that
the that the old priest class used to do
you know when you have the magic spells
you tend to make the magic spells work
for you
yeah i'm talking about yeah yeah that's
really all the law is a bunch of magic
spells
you read some [ __ ] out and you pay some
money to the gods and then also you can
build a building there
it's magic yeah yeah kind of yeah this
is a different interpretation of magic
and religion
it's the priest class that's exactly
what it is oracle man says as his
daughter wasn't she essentially
his property yes she would have yeah
because she was not married right and
ask yourself this that's legal but is
that moral
i don't think so well no obviously i
don't think so
honestly i don't even think that
children
under underage can really be considered
your property to any great extent
i mean yes you have the rights to make
certain decisions for them but there are
some decisions that i don't think you
have the right to make for them
once they get to a certain age as soon
as you hit 18 they're free
yeah it's like you really shouldn't
involve yourself in their [ __ ] life
anymore
yeah well you know i mean you know just
you know what i mean like interfering
with like how they're living or well if
they don't want you to
right and i think that was the problem
and i think she knew and we'll get into
this a little bit too in the
in uh the julia tafana case was that
you know yes she was a poisoner yes uh
she killed a lot of people and she sold
poison that killed a lot of people but
in a lot of ways um
murdering your husband back then was
kind of the only way to get out of [ __ ]
i mean women didn't really have any
rights you couldn't like
divorce if it's like if he was beating
you up or doing whatever he was doing
there wasn't a lot you could do about it
you know what i mean you could either
like sit there and take it or you could
like [ __ ] off the [ __ ] because you
couldn't like
report it to anybody they wouldn't do
anything yep
you know what i mean because you were
essentially property
once you know the laws you can get that
to work you can work to your advantage
and really no matter who you are
all right when you had guys like this
back under that old system
they were saying he would just go i know
what he was thinking he was like
the only thing they're looking for is
this this and this all right
so i can do everything else everything
else i can do
like i have her hold my [ __ ] bucket
while i'm crapping in it yeah
you know that the law says maybe that's
why they thought of these like
real really weird like creative things
because they were trying to like
circumvent that's what they're doing
yeah a criminal circumvent [ __ ] a
criminal a master criminal knows the law
a master criminal is a is a lawyer that
you know what i mean
that way he can manipulate the law this
is something that
civilians haven't figured out some of
them have figured it out but
if you're a criminal and you're and you
commit crimes for a living
you better have some bad ass [ __ ]
lawyers because they'll figure out how
you can do it
or to [ __ ] protect yourself yeah and
you should be a lawyer
that's another thing if you're a lawyer
you have power to commit crimes and get
away with it you know you're
because you know how to circumvent you
how to protect yourself from the
investigative prop
uh the investigative techniques it's all
kinds of [ __ ]
you can do organized crime families have
[ __ ] lawyers
just like here's an example that a
layman would understand
if you ever watch [ __ ] the godfather
the
they had council yaris and the council
of yerrys were lawyers
the mob had its own lawyer think of that
well yeah
you have to you have to have your own
lawyer
because half of your battles are going
to be fought in court
so every time you commit a crime you go
to your council gary and say i'm going
to kill this dude this and that and he's
going to okay
all right yeah make sure you do this and
this and this and don't do this and
don't do that
and hire and get this guy to do this and
this and that and uh
yeah that should work out and that's
exactly what they do
yeah that's exactly that's what
organized crime means yep
yeah and this guy here he's kind of
dirty we'll send him a few thousand
and then this guy over here will send
him of you it'll all work out
that's what they're doing i'm laughing
at the comments medieval marriage vows
i'll hold your crap bucket
yeah and i'll scratch your mangy balls
holy crap but yeah so at the end of that
story well wait no
like i said okay so like i said the most
famous painting of her which like i said
that's it right there
uh by gita rennie maybe not her or at
least not painted from life
looks a little idealistic if you ask
yeah this is another one of her
uh that's supposedly that kind of looks
like the same woman it might be
yeah yeah yeah there's a bunch and then
there's a that's a drawing
yeah i have i have a bunch
that's supposed to all be her yeah i bet
you one paint one painting is based on
the next
it probably is because yeah that's like
a statue that's very famous
now i will say here's something that's
interesting though
is that uh the very very famous
caravaggio painting and caravaggio is
actually one of my famous painters if
you don't know i actually
did like a sort of illustrated
novellette
that's sort of about caravaggio because
he killed a guy uh he murdered a dude
he had a very interesting life so i
wrote kind of like a thing about him
like a fictionalized kind of thing about
him that's illustrated with his stuff
but he has a very famous painting called
uh judith
uh beheading holofernes hola bernice
or whatever um which is right here
actually one of my
very favorite paintings right there very
gory
um some people have speculated that this
might uh have a relation back to
the case because they think that
caravaggio
might have been at beatrice chichen
chi's
execution he was certainly in rome at
the time
and um he was kind of interested in the
case so they think that he might have
used
that like as kind of a statement
uh on her you know on her execution like
how he didn't agree with it or whatever
so some people have speculated uh that
that might have something to do with it
also which
there's there's more uh evidence to
support that than there is about uh
gita renny painting that portrait of her
from life because that was
you know i'm not saying that's not her
i'm just saying that they don't think
that there's any way that that
particular painter had gotten
into the prison and painted her like
that she posed for it that's all so i
don't know if that's really her
but that seems to be like the image of
her that people have and like i said
people that talked about her did say
that she was actually
very beautiful so like i said it does
seem like
the legend of her that has come down to
us
is kind of based a lot around your 18th
19th century
romantics you know particularly shelly
like stendall wrote about
wrote about her um antonio narto
uh from the theater of cruelty bauhaus
wrote a song about
about him uh he did a play about her so
you know she's a very famous person and
there's like streets named after her in
italy so she's still like kind of
uh you know a celebrity like a
historical celebrity
what mango badger you deleted a guy from
the chat room by accident
whoops he accidentally i think he's
telling me it's hard to sell to say
i think he's telling me that he
accidentally deleted a guy from the chat
room
just for saying first
harsh although i do hate when people do
that yeah especially when they're not
first
i mean i think that's what he's trying
they weren't they weren't first yeah
because i saw that too and i was just
like oh whatever i didn't think anybody
did that i thought that was
an accident i thought that was like a
thing that you did back in like 2005 or
something yeah
i don't know
[Laughter]
do you want to do like uh commercials or
do a commercial break
are you sure yeah if somebody got
deleted from the chat room i don't know
how to undelete them
yeah i don't know how to do that yeah
that's so old
it is that's first
he said though doesn't mean anything he
can say first
even though like i said even though they
weren't first maybe they were well like
i said it was an accident
i wouldn't delete him i guess just be
like
[Laughter]
yeah you got it wrong don't delete
somebody for saying first i don't think
i didn't think anybody did that anymore
don't worry about it
i don't know how we undelete i don't
know that dude might be out there still
because we got one thumbs down that's
probably him
it's like hey some [ __ ] like deleted
me
just for saying first i was trying to be
funny oh my god
but yeah all right so you want to do a
commercial break you're going to do and
then we'll talk about
a lady that poisoned a whole bunch of
people yeah but maybe rightfully so i'm
not really sure we'll see it might have
been a situation like this one where the
dude had to come and you know what i
mean
i'm just saying all right so let's do
some commercials so we can
do whatever we need to do and uh we'll
be back in just a couple minutes
join us september 25th 26th and 27th for
a three-day special streaming event
strange realities to push the limits of
your
reality featuring authors academics
researchers occultists experiencers
podcasters and practitioners
[Music]
all presenting fresh cutting-edge
material and research
streaming live featuring presentations
by brent reagan
editor of alternate perceptions magazine
aaron gulias host of the saucer live
podcast david metcalf fighter and
researcher
alan greenfielder of secret cipher of
the euphemism
stephanie quick item and blogger red
pill junkie 14 researcher and explorer
tim bernal
timothy ritter host of strange familiars
dombrowski author and practitioner greg
bishop author of project
beta juni ashford host of 13 o'clock
recluse toast of the farm
jack montgomery folk magic joshua
cutchen author of thieves in the night
reverend michael carter alien contact
experiencer dr
future host of feature tony kale author
of memphis hoodoo
rin collier cultist soraya ascap first
of all
[Music]
all three days only twenty dollars
tickets and info available at strange
realitiesconference.com
brought to you by the conspira normal
podcast spiritnormal.com
[Music]
you love true crime i love true crime
and i've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume 3 is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the caddy
murders the carrie babies case the frog
boys
the alcasar murders and the anoka shira
park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slangs
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on amazon
or download the audiobook version from
audible.com and get ready for a chilling
journey through modern crime history
folks what's up you know i'm pointing at
you
you know some shit's up with it
so you're just gonna keep your eyes
closed huh
all right all right do it then
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
all right yeah we're back we're trying
to figure out how to how to undelete
somebody who was silenced in the chat
i'm sorry if one of the [ __ ] uh
moderators
it was an accident blocked you for
saying first
that's some lame [ __ ] it was the
accident yeah we don't we can't see the
control on how to unblock you and i'm
not i'm like afraid to push in she's
afraid
she's afraid of accidentally ending the
stream because i don't want to do that
so i want to start over
at this stage in my drunkenness it's
going to be really i don't know hey
mango badger do you have any controls on
your [ __ ] to um to unsilence him
i don't know but go ahead and go ahead
and continue
the show must go on yeah like i said
all right so the next thing we're going
to talk about
is this lady named julia tofana
now martin just said first is that the
guy is that the guy
oh yeah is that the guy he's back okay
[Laughter]
that wasn't my doing i told you there's
always
there's always one thing oh i heard the
door creep cookie throws the [ __ ]
door open like a [ __ ] wild west
[ __ ] saloon
[ __ ] walking dead she's usually what
were you gonna say
i don't remember it doesn't matter i'm
sure it doesn't please don't please
don't walk on the thing
please don't walk anything okay be
careful be careful
i'm always trying to like oh where she
goes over there they're going yeah
that's yeah
all right sorry all right mark first is
back
now you're going to be known as that
forever so yeah mark first
oh well okay let's go all right so we're
going to talk about this lady named
julia tofana now i actually never heard
of this
woman before she's not even on murder
pedia i don't even remember oh i found
her like
like i said from uh wikipedia people
that were
executed by the holy see she was right
after jordano bruno who
we should actually do a show about too
one of these days i was actually going
to add him to this one but i was like
nah he needs his own show
so now if everything that she confessed
to is correct
then she is indirectly
one of the most prolific serial killers
in history
as i have said before i am fascinated by
poisoners i don't know why because
i don't know maybe it's just because i'm
like kind of into chemistry or i'm into
like the stealthiness of it
i think it's because it's women well
women the killing men that's almost
always she got this thing that's like
this feminist murder
it's feminist i do like that murder
thing
it's like i'm not gonna stand up and
fight [ __ ] it's gonna be like a [ __ ]
fight i'm gonna [ __ ] give you some
[ __ ] you're gonna die later
and everybody's gonna feel sorry for me
that you died well it's a win-win
yeah i understand it
i'm telling you that's what i'm telling
you there are women evil well
no they're i mean they're women serial
killers too although i have to say it's
what is it like
90 10 men or maybe 85
15. it's yeah the men men serial killers
are all serial rapists it's about sex
it's about women it's about practicality
usually
yeah usually money yeah yeah
they usually they don't usually kill a
[ __ ] unless
they're gonna get a bunch of money out
of it or unless they're a real douche
yeah you know what i mean mostly money
look at the history of it or you do have
the the occasional weird person that
just like
likes to kill old people like in like
nurses and stuff yeah because they have
it's like a weird emotional thing like
they like to take care of them or
whatever
yeah and they say lunch house and by
proxy kind of [ __ ] yeah and i also think
it's the kind of thing that they're
an angel of mercy that they're releasing
them from sickness
that too i think there's a moment in the
afternoon alex rivera says poisoning is
feminine like celsius it's
feminine poisoning is feminine like
it's the perfect thing because if you do
it right
you can get away with it yeah and like i
said not only we get the dudes money
but everyone will also feel bad for you
and it's not feminine it's
effeminate feminine
is a [ __ ] oh whoa whoa look at the
kitty in a way
she's trying to hog [ __ ] huh she's like
i'm the star of the show yeah turn
around look at the camera
feminine is just a [ __ ] female
quality and of course that's awesome i
love feminine women
if feminine is a man that's like a woman
okay
it's it's it's like it's like if you saw
mel brooks history of the world
it's like the french dude from that
remember the [ __ ] bernays remember
bernays
don't get saucy with me bernays you know
he was effeminate
okay hold on i'm gonna get the cat out
here come here poop she's like what i'm
just sitting here running away the
camera
come here because he's like what i'm not
doing come here come here
she does it she's mad she's like don't
[ __ ] touch me she's like this is my
spot
jerk she's like don't [ __ ] touch me
you're all right as long as your big old
head isn't it
she actually has a little tiny head it
just looks really epic
but yeah poisoning is effeminate
it's bitch-like well no because
you have to think that in a lot of ways
um and apparently like in a lot of these
cases that i'm talking about now
the women didn't really have any other
recourse like they couldn't like the
dudes were a lot bigger than them they
didn't have any legal rights and
everything like that so it's like well
maybe if i put some poison in his food
and like it looks like an illness
then i'll be free and i won't have to
like go to prison or just you know
nothing bad will happen
so she can just go on to marry somebody
else because oh boohoo the dude just
died
of consumption or whatever so you know
it was making the best of a bad
situation i guess
so yeah so julia tofana um
so sh this was a 17th century so a few
years after the
beatrice case
now when she got caught she actually
confessed to not
killing 600 people directly but being
responsible for the deaths of 600 people
through her
poison business she was also an
entrepreneur
very early on and she got away with it
for
like 20 years because she was just that
good
but yeah so like i said now
we're talking about 17th century italy
here this is early 17th century um
as we said in the case of beatrice
chichen chi women were still essentially
property
a lot of them were just married off for
money for dowries for whatever
they didn't really have any particular
rights
you know they couldn't i thought men
could divorce but i don't think women
could
i guess they could run off but it's like
what are you gonna do then
so uh there was a lot of [ __ ] that was
happening outside of law lots
of it okay just because it was a law
didn't mean that that's what
the norm was i've i've studied my
history
the church was in la in charge of a lot
of the law
but there's a lot of [ __ ] that the
church wrote and this going back to this
period especially in the italian [ __ ]
scene and everything
is that the average person didn't follow
any of this [ __ ]
none of it at all they were not even
um uh um what do you call it
they were not prudent in other words you
know they didn't keep it in the pants
they were [ __ ] wild the average
person
and evidently [ __ ] children out of
wedlock was pretty rampant
well yeah i can imagine yeah it was not
it's not like what you think when you're
because they weren't real slick on the
birth control
no no no they had some but i don't think
it worked all that well and for the most
part
according to what the sources that i
read
and these are church sources the average
person was not even married
okay they had all kinds of children and
they weren't married
so don't project too much on what you're
seeing here this is um
this is only between the wealthy a lot
of the times
how much the wealthy followed these
rules well the sad thing about it though
is that i think a lot of times
um [ __ ] we know about history a lot of
it is based on people that were at least
upper middle class
because you didn't hear about what
happened to people because nobody wrote
the [ __ ] down
according to the church the poor people
actually were a lot more like us they
did whatever the hell they want they
were well yeah because
they were pretty liberated and for the
most part evidently the church didn't
care what they did
probably not it was only with really the
[ __ ] upper class that were being made
because they were the ones that were
getting money for they were the ones
that were getting money
and they were kind of considered to be
the important people or the real people
everybody else was kind of like a fake
person well yeah you were like subhuman
yeah
so they were poor right but you know
looking back on what they had to do i'd
rather be a [ __ ] sub human i'd rather
be a [ __ ] peasant
and i wouldn't be working i'd be one of
these dudes [ __ ] living out in the
[ __ ] woods i'd be a highwayman or
something
i'd just be stealing i told you i read a
book a while back
i think it was just called courtesans
and it was about
uh the demi monde you know of uh you
know
kind of high-class prostitutes
essentially yeah um in society like in
europe
they were probably better off and in a
lot of ways they were
i mean they could get away with stuff
that married women in society could not
get away with and
like reading that i was like it would
kind of suck to be a prostitute i would
not like that
at all but if it was a choice between
that
having your own pad having like [ __ ]
tons of money
having like hanging out and partying
with like the literati and stuff
i would much rather do that than have to
be some respectable
it's just pumping out kids and like not
doing anything to like upset anybody
it's just like today you know in
southern culture
you hear all this book all this [ __ ]
about racism of the past especially in
the south
but these are mostly kids and [ __ ]
people that are
after the 1960s they didn't really know
what the south was like
yeah there was racism but it wasn't
racism like you think it was
some of the freest women in the from the
freest people in the united states
period were [ __ ] new orleans
octoroons and quadrons
okay and there's a lot of they were the
geisha
of of of the new world really all kinds
of books are written about it
they had white women pretending to be
octoroons to gain rights
or to gain abilities there's a lot of
[ __ ] written about
all you guys got to do is research
octoroon balls and quadroon balls and
that whole [ __ ]
quadrune cultural phenomenon
because they were octoroon or quadrant
which is one-eighth or one-quarter black
they actually did they were fell into a
gray area of the law
and in society where they kind of
achieved freedom
and they were kind of the the mistress
or the geisha of the south
um it was a ticket to
life in downtown new orleans in an upper
scale apartment and [ __ ] kind of what
you would
and and a man that they're in a
relationship that where the guy actually
loved you
and a family and um
you know kind of what we would consider
to be like a normal life
because in the southern aristocracy of
that time
relationships between men and women were
all arranged and they were about money
well yeah i feel like marriage for up
until relatively
recently was always like a financial
transaction right essentially
the rich southern man did not was
did not choose his wife that was that
was arranged to him
um through his family that was who he
had to marry
and it was about a merger between
southern empires usually or southern
rich southern families this is rich
people
there was no dating scene or freedom or
anything the only
the only freedom that southern man had
when he had money in terms of
relationships was that he could choose a
mistress
yeah and legally the only mistress he
could choose were these quadrants and
octoroons
and and he shoot and that was a
relationship based upon love
more anything else so he loved the
mistress not the wife
the wife was just giving it well like i
said i feel like that's happened i'm not
saying obviously nothing is
you know across the board but i do feel
like you in general even going back to
like
before the middle ages and [ __ ] like
that and i'm not talking about peasants
and stuff like that because i feel like
those people
you know i don't want to say oh they
were freer than other people in some
ways they were i mean but in a lot of
ways their lives
sucked because they didn't have any
money or no resources or power
no legal system to protect them or right
so that sucked right but in a lot of
ways they didn't have
i mean once you got into like higher
classes they had
a stricture of [ __ ] that they had to put
up with particularly women
you didn't really i feel like poor women
probably had
a little bit more freedom than upper
class women a little bit
yeah and then um what you hear today a
lot you know they're condemning
all of american culture based upon the
the situation in the history of the
[ __ ] old south
it just does not compare you cannot
compare the old south with
with today even back in those days
the culture of the old south had more in
common
with feudal japan than it did with the
rest of [ __ ]
of the united states it was very much
like feudal japan
it's all gone that now though that's
you know what i mean it's not a problem
it did not survive the war
and even before the war it was already
vanishing
uh but they just keep bringing that up
over and over and over again
that's long gone you know what i mean
i have a book somewhere i don't know
where it is maybe it's up in the attic
but it was all like
um letters and all kind of like um
documents from uh women of that time
period
yeah and it's fascinating it's like a
fascinating look at like their
day-to-day lives
yeah which like i said i would not have
wanted to live back then [ __ ] that
but yeah so no it would have been boring
by today's standards
it would have been pretty boring
especially living in a town
well i mean everything would have been
like i said it's you know it was
different for men they always could
do more [ __ ] than it was boring for them
no i'm not talking about boring i'm
talking about like just being able to
like
live and like do what you wanted i feel
like women didn't really have that
luxury back in the 17 1800s if you
the only really exciting lives if you
ask me and this is everything
based upon what i've read from people
that were there
would have been out in indian territory
that's where the action was
well that's what i thought but you were
gonna probably get killed if you weren't
on top of your game out there
and you had to go through a process that
was called
going engine so what they called it you
had to become an indian basically
and those dudes were [ __ ] on top of
their [ __ ] gang
all right there was no joke it's raining
oh yeah i guess so [ __ ] we just got hit
by a came out of nowhere
yeah this is dagobah if i were to go
back in a time machine in the old
america
i would have been jeremiah johnson
basically that's what the kind of [ __ ] i
would have done
would that have been fun no but it would
have been adventurous but i'm used to
the field it'd been like in the army
well the thing about it is that you have
to like consider
well would it have been more fun or not
maybe more fun but
less sucky than
like more mainstream kind of life yeah
and it would have been probably
not i think mainstream life would have
been suck here that's what i said yeah
especially in a city
places like new york and on the eastern
seaboard terrible
terrible can i have some more bread sir
here's our [ __ ] you know what i mean
there's some oliver twist [ __ ] going on
out there you know what i mean
people were dying in those cities of
starvation and disease bad
very bad clean living was out in the
field
with the indians the mentality of the
native americans was a lot more what we
would consider to be reasonable in some
cases
depending on the tribe the nation there
were many nations
there wasn't one indian nation there
were lots of them she's part native
american
so [ __ ] you know i mean [ __ ] jen
well jenny's not big into that culture
but every
pretty much people my dad is though
pretty much anybody who's been here in
terms of
his grandpa's who've been here longer
than four or five generations you're
gonna have you're gonna be part native
american that's just
they all bred in and it they were
just as diverse as european societies
there were a lot of different indian
nations all fighting each other
and outsiders and it was a bunch of
[ __ ] changing alliances and stuff
and they were kind of like the pirates
of the high seas especially out in the
great plains
like the lakota all right you could not
be a [ __ ] and be a lakota
i'm i'm getting off track i'm jumping
i'm talking about indians because it's
good go ahead and back yeah you always
seem to i know i can't
i can't control it it's that traditional
man crush on the [ __ ] american indian
man those dudes were affected
well they were the conan of the new
world man they were the conan's of the
new world
okay everybody liked your oliver twist
impression did you like that
may i have some more may not have samosa
that's the [ __ ] way that
that was kind of the culture where white
people came from and i just kind of
thought of like [ __ ] tiny tim then
from yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah god bless us everyone
yes so uh all right so like we're saying
so 17th century italy uh you know like i
said we're not talking about peasant
women unfortunately because they don't
usually get talked about
we're talking about women in kind of
like society quote unquote
they didn't really have a lot of options
i mean you could pretty much
uh get married uh which you know that
was kind of
the option and be supported and be
someone's property or you could stay
single and be a hooker
um or uh ideally
which a lot of women liked they could be
a wealthy widow except to do that you
first had to get married and then you
had to bump off the husband yeah and
then you get a boyfriend
then comes that's where julia tofana's
business came in
um and like i said there she wasn't the
only one there was a lot of other women
providing these types of
apothecary services uh on the black
market
for women that were just like i need to
get out of this situation
um and i don't really have a lot of
options so you know
i'm just saying that was she saw a gap
in the market and
exploited it so
so now like i said there poisoning was
like
pretty [ __ ] widespread yeah so
because poisoning
is i think one like i said i think one
of the reasons that i find it so
fascinating is because
you are murdering somebody but it's not
you don't have to do
like you don't have to get all yucky
about it you don't have to like you know
cut their head off you don't like
dismember them in the bathtub and get
all dirty and stuff like that you can
like
just slip some [ __ ] into their food and
they'll maybe just get sick and die and
it's just kind of like
you can just waltz away from it like you
know what i mean so i just there's
something very appealing about that i
guess for a lot of people
but it's like so there had been a lot of
that kind of [ __ ] going on
um like i said i think i mentioned this
on one of our other poisoning shows
was it arsenic that's known as the
inheritance powder yeah i think in
france they call it the inheritance i
think
it was because it was so widespread that
people were like offing their realm
well there's a point where you get to
where you can't really like you you know
that they probably did it but you can't
prove it
you know what i mean that's another
thing plausible deniability that's like
is another thing that portland gives you
so uh julia tofana they don't know a lot
about
her background or her childhood or
anything like that
but um they think she was born in
palermo
in sicily uh around about 16 20.
um now her mom
uh so julia was a chip off the old block
here
her mom sofania uh was also
executed in 1633 for murdering her
husband
so you know julia was like hey that
seems like a good idea i think i'm gonna
carry on mom's
work i suppose i don't know if the dude
was a dick or whatever but she did get
executed for
killing her husband now
julia tafana apparently
allegedly also killed her first husband
i don't know she killed him or if
she just he just died of natural causes
because people dropped dead all the time
back then which like i said is another
reason why poisoning was so effective
because people were dropping dead of
disease all the time and who can tell
the difference
now she had a daughter named giro lama
so she uh after her husband died
under probably mysterious circumstances
she moves to naples and then she moves
to rome and she decides that she's going
to go into business for herself
selling poisons but
she's not selling them as poisons
because that would be crazy what she
does
is she makes this concoction and she
disguises it
as cosmetics but
it's kind of a thing where everyone kind
of knows like they come in they're like
hey i want that new lipstick shade
wink wink it's that kind of [ __ ] so
she's doing it like on the dl
now apparently this um so she gets like
her daughter
involved she gets like um some other
co-conspirators like some other women
that are like working with her
so she starts gaining like a reputation
around rome as hey you want to get rid
of that
abusive husband of yours go down there
and buy some
lipstick you know what i mean and like
put it in his food
so she would put it in like these really
nice bottles that looked like
different cosmetics you know what i mean
so she wasn't like stupid she knew what
she was doing
so they also um they think
that they might have also got a priest
in on the action
to kind of like give them some
legitimacy i guess
like they don't know if they don't know
exactly if he was well he's kind of like
a friend of theirs he's got to keep
having fresh with a fresh supply of
souls i guess
coming in you know yeah and it probably
he's probably handling burials
well he was supposedly the guy that was
like their arsenic supplier
yeah which i don't know how you get to
be the arsenic supplier for a poisoner
business but apparently this
dude managed it
what she developed was this poison
which she called aqua tofana now like i
said
she packaged it so that it looked like
various like
youth creams or like for one time which
i thought was particularly ballsy
she uh packaged it to look like kind of
like holy water
like she was selling like a bottle of
holy like it was all pretty and [ __ ] i
was like
nice i like your style but uh yeah so
she did that
they're not sure um exactly
what i mean aqua to fauna has its own
wikipedia page because it's a very
famous
poison and i'll get into maybe one of
the reasons why later on
they think that there was arsenic in it
there was probably lead in it and there
was maybe belladonna in it
but they're not entirely sure like what
the combination
was they do know that it was tasteless
and colorless and that it could be put
into food or drink um
and that it would you would have to
administer it over several days
and it would mimic the symptoms
of several different diseases so it
didn't look like
an obvious poisoning you know what i'm
saying so that's why she got away with
it for so long because like i said
this is like [ __ ] 17th century people
are dropping dead all the time
of you know various diseases and it you
know
looked like one of those
so yeah so she had like like i said she
had the [ __ ] that looked like perfume
bottles and all this other kind of stuff
like i said the [ __ ] that looked like
holy water was actually called the mana
of saint nicholas of
berry which was like a healing oil or
something
so and the nice thing about it too
so you can tell i'm kind of like i'm
kind of like
admiring her gumption i guess um
not only did it mimic the symptoms of a
lot of
very common diseases but also after the
person died you couldn't really detect
it
so this was some good [ __ ] like i said
they're not entirely sure what
the proportions of the stuff was they
know like roughly what the ingredients
were but not what the proportions were
and it was uh in a liquid so you would
give the first
dose they usually put like in their soup
or in their wine or whatever
so the first dose would just make them
like really tired and like really weak
then they would give them a second dose
and then they would start having like um
they would get really thirsty they would
have stomachaches
um vomiting that type of stuff and then
um the nice thing about this too was
that
since the person was sick and it took
several days for them to die
um the wife could make sure that
she was in the will and like make sure
that everything was sorted out to her
satisfaction
before the dude died you know what i
mean so he didn't just like drop dead
immediately like it took us several days
of him being like really sick and
everything
so you would um then you would
administer a third or fourth dose
over a couple of days uh and then that
would kill the person
um and then in a lot of ways and i i
guess
that uh julia tiffany like maybe
suggested this as well
was like hey like for extra [ __ ] why
don't you go
and like demand that they're being like
a postmortem
because they won't find anything so
you'll be free and clear
you'll look super innocent and you'll
get all the [ __ ] money
everyone's a winner so that's kind of
like what
another service that she provided as
well now
julia jafana did this [ __ ] for 20
years 20 years that's how good her
[ __ ] poison was
because like i said it just looked like
people were dropping dead at disease it
happened all the time
so you know the only reason
she got caught i mean i guess but she
might have got caught for some other
reason
the only reason she got caught or so the
story goes
was that in 1650 there was this woman
and she decided she was gonna poison her
husband so she went and bought some
other [ __ ]
she put it in his soup and you didn't
need much you only needed like a drop or
two like this was really really
powerful [ __ ] so she puts it in his soup
he's going to eat the soup and as the
spoon is going to his mouth
she changes her mind and says hey don't
eat that
i poisoned it what she backed out
what she got cold feet why did you say
oh don't eat that like
i sneezed it or i don't know you could
think of something else other than like
i poisoned it
so she said please don't eat that um so
i guess what happened was she said
please don't eat that he was like why
not and he got really suspicious about
it because i guess he was a dick so he
suspected that
she might have poisoned him so he like
beat the [ __ ] out of her and she finally
admitted hey i poisoned it
and so he turned her in
well that's an opportunity for a new
wife yeah he's like i'm gonna get me a
new wife
i'll get a new one yeah yeah i'll trade
her in first trade
for a new one yeah what was she thinking
we'll see if
look if okay now if you're gonna go to
all the trouble yeah you can go to the
woman and buy it or maybe
don't eat that because he's going to be
like why not what'd you do to it
yeah you know what i mean because if
he's a dick deep down he knows she
probably wants to kill me
so there was more to that story there's
more to this
i'm just saying that's how the story
goes the the story goes that this is how
julia uh julian
so so yeah so the husband turns this
lady in
they torture the lady as they did and
she finally admits
where she bought the poison which was
from julia tofana
so now what happened so the cops or the
authorities at the time
start looking for julia tofana julia
runs to a church
and does like [ __ ] quasimodos like
sanctuary sanctuary now the church had
to give you that
so they did give it to her um
but what happened was so she's in the
church and they're protecting her
because that was what they did
but then somebody started a rumor around
town that julia had poured the poison
into the water supply
and so everybody turned against her i
don't know who started the rumor this is
like i said this is just how the story
goes
uh so then public sentiment turned
against her
and uh so everybody kind of like stormed
the church and dragged her out
and she got arrested you're like [ __ ]
sanctuary killer yeah
that [ __ ] she hadn't like poisoned the
water supply as far as i know
but uh somebody started that relative
you know maybe somebody in the
authorities was like
hey she you know just to like get the
mob to like turn against her and it
worked
so they dragged her out they arrested
her and they started torturing her
because they just
couldn't stop torturing people it was so
fun
this was an area where they'd take a
bunch of cats and throw them in a basket
and then throw the basket in the fire
just to see the cats jump out and [ __ ]
you know what i mean you're not i can't
imagine that
then they would take a bear if somebody
did that now they'd be like serial
killer
yeah you're going to a mental home bye
they'd take a bear and tie a damn
[ __ ] rope around his leg and put it
to us and then stick it into the ground
and [ __ ] beat on the bear
you're not talking about not talking
about modern people they were [ __ ]
crazy
yeah they they clearly had some yeah
they all kind of needed their asses beat
you know i mean but i'm not sure you
know what this is i probably wouldn't
make a difference that's what i mean i
was just gonna say that they were so
used to like filth and pestilence and
violence that it's like even if you beat
their ass they'd be like yeah i suppose
so it's like
they're not gonna learn yeah they
wouldn't learn
i don't know why that is but here's
what's funny about the situation
i could say this and not come off as
racist because these people are all the
same [ __ ] racial group as me
there's somebody where you take a
barbarian and you take them out of the
[ __ ] woods and put them into an urban
environment they get worse
all right had you released these people
kind of thinned out the population so
there weren't as many of them and
released them out into the [ __ ] new
world like america
they had been a lot better off well
they'd have had other things to do
yeah you can't take people like this
and [ __ ] they're people human beings are
just not built for that
they're not built for what you doing
poke
stop tearing [ __ ] up she's tearing up
all my patterned envelopes that i use to
send t-shirts
i have a pile of them over there and she
decided she's going to pull them all out
and eat them
human beings aren't really meant for um
urban life uh they're barely meant for
[ __ ] farming villages
uh we're unchanged we're not really
supposed to be alive actually
human beings are supposed to be tribal
level kind of hunter gatherers
that's what they evolved as for [ __ ]
hundreds of thousands of years
stop it poop stop [ __ ] doing that
[ __ ] what are you doing
why look then she goes [ __ ] you goes
right back to it
she doesn't listen to me no i know you
need to control your children
okay you need to control your children
she's my choice yeah that's how that's
how that's how a man is supposed to do
it
put that [ __ ] on the woman these are
your children okay pookie will you stop
it look at that [ __ ]
she's tearing it up she's turned it up
no no
no look at that [ __ ] i want to show that
to the people
look at that she loves paper you tore it
up
oh you're in big trouble oh yeah
[Music]
i took them from you and she's like what
what happened
she was like why are you why are you
being a dick she's mad it was making a
fun noise yeah
why are you like always [ __ ] up my
fun
human evolution has not caught up with
technology it just hasn't clearly
clearly the human being really is kind
of unchanged
in [ __ ] 6 000 years well it goes up
and down a little bit
but only for our point of view if you
were to really if an
alien were to come and look at an
ancient egyptian a modern person and a
medieval person they wouldn't see much
different in between them
all right it'd be like
a human being seeing the difference
between a chimpanzee and orangutan and a
gorilla they're all apes
you know that's what you're dealing with
it's going to take
first of all the whole the whole [ __ ]
city and urban angle
i think that's i think that's a wrap
technology has kind of made that the
dead mall of the future
so human beings are going to go back to
their normal environment of being in
excerpts and suburbs everything brought
to your house because the internet what
the [ __ ] do you need a city for
you can do everything from your house
now it doesn't matter where you live the
opportunities are all the same
so that will alleviate a lot of the
stress
then we're going to have to [ __ ]
worry about population density we have
to thin out this population density just
a little bit and that's going to happen
you watch you'll see
it's going to take a couple generations
but it'll all work itself out
all right that's all i'm going to say
jenny jenny your child
has ripped up these [ __ ] envelopes
look at all the [ __ ] debris
oh pokey pokey what are we gonna do with
you
she's looking for more i'm too i'm too
permissive she's [ __ ] permissive
well i'm a disciplinarian on these
children what are you doing she's too
cute i can't do anything
i call myself disciplinarian when did
you see me discipline that cat never
never i never disciplined that kid what
are you doing well it's like
i like i said i have the big pile of
like padded envelopes
she tore them up and i'm just like i can
buy new ones
there's only one of them it was only one
of them it's all right i have a bunch
more yeah they're coming up
come here i just i don't want her to be
mad at me
well she's mad because we're doing the
show yeah clearly
she's like you guys are talking to the
lights too much she's making her little
come here i call her i call her the
grumbler she wants me to come down
she doesn't like i said she doesn't she
meows sometimes but mostly she just
makes these little noises
but without opening her mouth yeah but
it's like it's a different inflection
like whatever she means
sometimes it means hey stop touching me
or sometimes it means like
hey come here we're gonna go do
something fun let's see how the comments
are doing let's see how the comments are
doing
yeah okay um
yeah so somebody's a bit alex goes wait
a minute bear baiting isn't socially
acceptable anymore i never really got
bear baiting i don't know what kind of
bears they were doing this how did you
even think of that
how would you even think of that it's
ridiculous i don't know what kind of
bears they're
they were doing this to know if they
were brown bears or what
an american black bear would run from
that they just they they
they're yeah they're like i'm known out
of here by cowardly
kind of cowardly they wouldn't they're
not there they wouldn't be good well
they're just like i don't want to get
involved i don't want to get involved
i just want to go through like people's
trash cans man i'm just over here
minding my own business leave me alone
poor babies i can't say like i said
i don't know i i
i feel like i'm more bothered by like
violence against man now she's just no
violence against people she's trying to
tear up these [ __ ] magazines that
people sent us
you know what i mean yeah you probably
don't want to have this okay you
you are out of control you are out of
[ __ ] control put her on your put her
on your lap
okay you can play with her come here now
she's running
she's come here
oh pokey you are incorrigible
look at your little face you are
definitely being bad
everybody wants to see you yeah even
though you're being a little brattling
you're definitely being bad
that's okay mommy still loves you
she's like i'm gonna bite you i'm gonna
bite you
[Laughter]
okay all right go ahead and continue
with the show i got it
well that's all she wanted and she just
wanted daddy to pay attention yeah
she's like i just want to bite you
[Laughter]
you know what she did the other day like
like i said she likes to she knows when
the shower runs like when she hears the
shower running she comes running like
from wherever she is because she's like
ooh time for closet play
yeah because whenever we go in there
like we throw towels on her and roll her
around in him
and she loves it yeah so the other day
tom was doing that and he's like
throwing a towel on her she's like
rolling around she's having a good time
she's like [ __ ] with his dvds that
are in there and [ __ ] like that
and then he like stopped and then he
turned around like to look for some
clothes or whatever
and she very deliberately looked at the
back of his leg
as though she was looking for the best
place to strike yeah and then she went
ah yeah like right on this
but like just right on his shin but i
loved that considering
look like where am i going to bite this
guy where's the best
oh that's a good spot and then she did
it i saw her do it it was so funny i
wish i had like [ __ ] videotapes it
wasn't any clothes though
[Laughter]
well yeah that's the problem they've
been caught in the [ __ ] eclipse
that damn swinging eclipse okay go ahead
this swinging clip i was you know what
you know what's very funny
i was thinking about that this morning
because i said remember
earlier i was like oh get some footage
of pookie whatever it is she's doing
because she was just sleeping mostly
today and i then i was thinking to
myself
oh i should videotape her like
doing the closet [ __ ] because that's
always really funny but then i'm like i
can't do that because you're always like
running around in there naked
yeah so i was like well i guess we can't
do that so i did actually think of that
earlier when i was thinking of like
she's being [ __ ] crazy stop it poop
no
come here she's like what the problem
what's the problem just let me tell you
no come here
she's gonna try to tear [ __ ] up don't do
it she's like what and then she looks at
us like
what the [ __ ] she's like so i'm allowed
to play with some things but not other
things
i don't understand she doesn't
understand thank you mango
thank you very much 15 quid for pookie
oh thank you very much yeah
keep them flash bulbs [ __ ] coming
people we're gonna have to like buy
some new meat sticks yeah mango mango is
the only person that's [ __ ]
contributed
if you enjoy the show please [ __ ]
like share subscribe contribute please
also like i said if you want to be on uh
patreon you get to like
i started doing polls yeah you can like
choose what the next movie and what the
next topic is yeah
so that should be fun yeah the the show
we'll see how that
shakes out tomorrow the show is more
than half over if you'd like to
contribute go ahead and [ __ ] send us
a super chat thank you
stop it oh no i got you no
oh i'm trying to get you
she's like what was i doing because
you're being bad
oh you're being bad poor baby
[Laughter]
all different kind of video with naked
time running around that's what i was
thinking it's like
i did tons of money with that [ __ ] you
could you probably would with your
little with your little tiny
butt yeah so it can be all kinds of all
kinds of gay porn and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah that will exploit the hell out of
that [ __ ] that's right
but yeah so yeah so she tried to go into
the church
for sanctuary which worked for a little
while until somebody started the whole
rumor about her poisoning the entire
water supply somebody got pissed off
there was a mob
they dragged her out and they arrested
her then they tortured her
as they did because that was just what
they're like okay well we arrested you
now thank you very much
thank you time thank you victor thank
you oh can you get a
13 o'clock shirt and you give five
dollars to beijing i know beijing kind
of
exhausted the thing about it is i feel
bad about
beijing because she never comes in here
hardly
yeah she only comes in my office when
i'm not in here
yeah she comes in to like steal the toys
off my
shelves for whatever reason this morning
she was
on her i came in the cop the kitchen to
make coffee
and she was on her little scratching
throne and i was like hey princess
what's up and i went to peter and she
did that thing like she kept moving her
head like ah
don't touch me don't touch me but it's
like she wants you to touch her but then
she doesn't
yeah um victor um go ahead and send us a
uh
send jenny a private message on facebook
or instagram
yeah remind me about the size and the
design you have size well he wants 13
o'clock
and then we got to get your uh
information uh your address and
everything well i should have that
already should happen
because i sent him already okay what
size do you what size you vic
i don't remember offhand okay one i
think i'm more of a beijing than a
pookie
yeah i wish she would be on the show
more but it's like she's very
her personality and pookies are like
opposite beijing is like
super aloof and it's like
she wants she'll like come in like hey
pet me
beam and then you do it but then she's
like [ __ ] off yeah she's very weird like
that
she's always what size shirt you want
vic i should have it if you want the
same one as yeah but it's easier because
we just sent him i mean i got
two okay yeah right that's good yeah i
have
i have i actually have a blank to it
in the [ __ ] yeah so they start torturing
her and she says
um yeah i've been selling poison since
1633
maybe earlier so i may be responsible
for the death of
up to 600 dudes
um yeah so
they take her to the campo di fiore in
rome in 1659
uh also her daughter and three of the
people who worked with her
and uh executed her now
creepily and this also kind of pa plays
back into the first case we were talking
about
they also arrested 40
of the poor women that had bought poison
from her that had poisoned their
husbands
and executed them as well however
some more upper-class women that had
purchased poisons
um they got much lighter sentences
not surprisingly they were just put in
jail for a short time we're just saying
hey
don't do that again because they had
money so it was fine
but they executed 40 other women also
who had bought the poison
um what a lot of the more
monied suspects said was that oh
i had no idea this was poison i thought
it was just
cosmetics they just like played dumb
right is what they did
that's what i would do wouldn't you that
seems like the best
would be the best option yeah that i
started yeah i just went to this
apothecary and i bought some lipstick i
didn't know that
that's what they sold me right i didn't
know it had arsenic in it
right arsenic was probably in a lot of
that [ __ ] anyway i know that they were
putting arsenic
and mesa makeup to [ __ ] make it look
brighter or something uh what was that
like you know
what this is very interesting and i had
heard about this but i read about it
extensively when i did
um i wrote an article about
emily gautreau who was the woman who was
the subject of the very famous john
singer sergeant painting madam x
uh which i saw in new york she was a
fascinating person we should actually
maybe do a whole
show on her because i i always wanted to
see like a movie done about her
but one thing that she was very known
for was she had a very striking
uh profile and she was also super super
pale
and one of the rumors i'm not sure if
it's entirely true
it may be um was that she would use
arsenic or lead or something like that
to make herself paler because that was
kind of her
one of her claims to fame like one of
the things that made her super striking
like in society
so there there was like a lot of
poisonous [ __ ] like to make your
skin look whiter and
to what extent did they know i mean they
must have known that that was poisonous
and that that was bad for you i would
think to some extent maybe they didn't
really know
well even probably even today there's
people that'll take things that are
[ __ ] poisonous and bad for you but
they do it because it makes them look
better
yeah so it's like i guess we can like
[ __ ] on people back then for like being
stupid but we do the same we should do
the same thing we do the same thing
right i'm drinking alcohol for gracing
right this is poison also well [ __ ]
perform performance
enhancing drugs and [ __ ] like that you
know what i mean it's like something
that's just bad for you they take it
anyway
yeah i'm gonna take trembling make you
[ __ ] huge yeah it makes you crazy you
want to kill everything you see
but [ __ ] it well i feel like
probably just as back then i mean i feel
like i don't know i don't know
you know i don't know her she lived a
long time ago but i feel like emily
gaucho was like well
my paleness is one of the things that
defines me
so even if this stuff is bad for me it
will probably take a long time to affect
me and in the meantime
yeah you know i will get all this thing
i'll get all this fame and like all
right i'll look beautiful so it's worth
it so i feel like they were doing like a
risk assessment
perhaps but like i said man we got to do
a show about her i'm so i don't know for
some reason i found
her i found her a really interesting
person
and i think that she would be a good
topic
for a show yeah she would be a good type
i wrote a screenplay about her actually
because i think that would be like a
good movie but yeah
so so she got executed like 40 other
people got executed her daughter got
executed
like all the women that work for her got
executed and
as i said she may have she may be
responsible for the deaths of about 600
men that's what she
i mean considering like what her
customer base was and stuff like that if
all those people that bought the poison
from her had actually like gone through
with it
then that's then she was indirectly
responsible for that many deaths making
her
indirectly one of the most prolific
serial killers
of all time now the reason why aqua
tofana
is so famous and still has its own
wikipedia page to this day
is because of the lingering rumor that
it was used to kill
wolfgang amadeus mozart now like i said
mozart who we should probably also do a
show about him because he was also a
fascinating person
him and his dad and his sister that
whole is that within the scope of the
show though
um i don't know i was yeah but i always
found it
i always thought it fascinating well we
could talk about
whether or not how he died right because
nobody really knows
right and that's what i'm saying so he
died at 35.
now interestingly the reason that some
people think that he was poisoned
specifically with aqua tofana was
because
he himself said that
he apparently said or
wrote in a letter like before he died
like when he was sick
he said and i quote i feel definitely
that i will not last much longer he was
35 years old
i am sure that i have been poisoned i
cannot rid myself of this idea
someone has given me aqua to fauna
and calculated the precise time of my
death
that's what he said that's what he said
now i don't now nobody thinks
nowadays that he was poisoned he
probably died of something
mundane like a lot of people i'm not
saying that it's without the bounds of
possibility that anybody been poisoned
he might have been
but you guys got to see this [ __ ] what
cookie fell asleep on her back pocket
did she
yeah get the camera well she's not
asleep now
okay get her get her get her
she's looking at me what's up poking you
falsely
oh pokey [ __ ] tail starts laying on
her back with all her [ __ ]
all four limbs up in the air she fell
back asleep oh okay
it's ridiculous man that's like a person
laying on her back pookie you are
[ __ ] ridiculous
what the hell happened what you doing
wake up okay
don't wake her up no okay you're so mean
no
i'm not even on camera where are they no
whoa dude without it wait what are you
doing i don't know what i'm doing
let me handle this i got two i am
letting you know i gotta turn
back i gotta turn around i gotta turn
right back
look what you're doing i gotta turn
around backwards but yeah so
like i said is it possible that mozart
got poisoned
sure um do i think he got poisoned
probably not i mean yeah he was really
young when he died but a lot of people
died young back then
um interestingly though even though most
experts think yeah it's probably
he probably did not get poison but
i did find a thing that said some
historians later on that were going
through like they found like a lot of
his original manuscripts and like a lot
of his uh original scores and stuff
they did say that in the original
manuscript
of the magic flute one of his most
famous uh
operas they did find an unusual amount
of arsenic on the pages
which that was one of the main
ingredients of aqua tofana
so could someone have poisoned him maybe
i think he had cancer i don't think it
was i don't think it was cancer but
um there was a lot of diseases that
could kill you back then
even at 35. um
i do feel like i mean and i'm not saying
because amadeus is one of my favorite
movies of all time
but that was based on a play that was
based on
a legend about salieri and how
he hated mozart because
for whatever because he was like a
genius and sallier was just a workman
like composer and he was like jealous
and stuff
so that you know the rumor grew up that
he had killed him
but i feel like that the reality doesn't
really play that out like from the
they were actually kind of friends and
they collaborated on some [ __ ] what's up
with this game so i don't think that
anything
uh happened with that but like i'm
saying that's why aqua tofana
the poison that she invented was
actually famous
for centuries after her death even being
implicated in mozart's death even though
probably not but he did actually
think to say that somebody poisoned me
with that [ __ ] because it was so famous
and like i said even nowadays the name
of it is still famous
even though they're not sure they think
they know what's in it but they don't
know what the proportions
of were in it but it did seem to be that
it was a good poison in the sense that
it was undetectable um it would kill the
person
over several days and look like a
disease so it looked like a natural
death
and also it could not be found in an
autopsy i don't know if i'm sure it
would be found in autopsy nowadays
but if they were looking for it because
i know some poisons
are they don't necessarily look for it
if the death isn't otherwise
suspicious because there are particular
tests that have to be done for
particular poisons
and if they don't think if they don't
suspect homicide in a particular case
then they're not going to look for the
[ __ ]
but back then if somebody just died of
something that
looked like you know some common disease
at the time then they weren't gonna
check and see if the person got poisoned
uh and even if they did i don't think
they had the technology to
see if it had like really been that so i
feel like that's why she got away with
it for so long
she had a whole [ __ ] business doing
this [ __ ]
you know yeah she was the bill gates of
poison in your [ __ ] what's your life
which like i said you have to say it's
not
but you have to think okay so i'm not
saying like all 600 dudes like deserve
to be poisoned because i'm sure they
didn't
but um some of them probably did i mean
to be honest with you and some of the
women were just probably like they were
at the end of their tether and they're
just like i can't
i don't have any recourse what am i
gonna do you couldn't divorce the dude
you couldn't
what are you gonna do you're gonna go to
the law so it's like i'm just gonna go
get some poison i'm just gonna off him
and then
i'll get the money oh thank you very
much celtic angel thank you for beijing
thank you very much everybody's
remembering keep it rolling let's see
them [ __ ] flashlights i'm about to
bring her on the show one of these days
except she'll be like the whole time get
me
out yeah and neko got his shirt glad you
enjoyed it bro she
he liked it if you guys want any shirts
[ __ ] we can make a donation right in
the super chats of 20
at least at least 20 and [ __ ] if you
don't have a shirt we'll
we'll send you a shirt i have to send
one to melanie as well because i think i
forgot to send
she sends me stuff like over uh paypal
all the time
so i feel like i have to send her how
much is left on on the show that's
pretty much pretty much it i mean you
know all right well
holy crap we didn't even go to three
hours this time no good
it's a normal sized show what happened
it's a normal sized show
nico always says lol i'm a girl because
you call everybody bro
do i yeah i don't realize that i'm joke
i'm drunk
i'm just it's all part of the show
everyone's bro it's kind of like in
california where everyone's dude
yeah yeah dude
it's a genderless journal yeah i'm just
gonna roll with that because i don't
really know
do we have oh well look he's over here
she's [ __ ] wondering why the [ __ ] it
was why is the show still going on why
are we paying attention
it's gonna be all right pokey we're
gonna stop talking to the light box here
in a minute oh
okay we're gonna stop talking she's so
mad at us right yeah she's like this
[ __ ] [ __ ] sucks
she's so mad at us yeah it's still light
outside though
is it yeah holy crap i can't believe
we've gone down in a minute i can't
believe it you sure you don't want to
get drunk
we gotta go we gotta finish the [ __ ]
stand i gotta watch some uh a new [ __ ]
too
because i get we gotta live stream
tomorrow and do a new so you don't wanna
watch stan
yeah i do okay but we gotta watch some
other show rush
let's see what everybody's talking about
all right we don't have to we could
review the stand tomorrow if we
could do that too if we watch enough of
it to remember we've got four hours of
the stand left
oh what time is it okay it's quarter to
eight here
can i stay awake for another four hours
well i see
okay oracle woman's making sure oracle
mom
moan is making sure that i know that
she's a woman the only way i'm gonna be
100 sure you're a woman you send me
video you got to send me and jenny a
video
you're going to be breaking it off break
that [ __ ] off it's got to be topless
you're going to get away and then it's
going to be a boob off between
you and you get in trouble it's me
you just called me by your first wife
yeah i know that i know that in that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] time i'm drunk be you and jen oh
yeah big trouble i haven't [ __ ] said
you're in bigger trouble
i haven't said her name and [ __ ] how
long i don't remember last time [ __ ]
but you have called me by her name
before i have but that was a long time
ago
that was that had to be about six years
ago
i love it you guys are seeing the real
[ __ ] right here
yeah i'm [ __ ] loaded wow
let's go be alright i have but seriously
i don't know no no that [ __ ] was like
that much that was okay that was like
one
i've actually kept it together i guess
you're [ __ ] up what are you talking
about i am too but yeah but
not to the extent that you are i
actually still like remember [ __ ] yeah
i'm still fairly coherent i think right
yeah yeah you go here
last week you weren't i've got to say i
was kind of well that's what i'm saying
you were doing the show talking in
circles
about that this is why i didn't say it
again and this is why i didn't want to
watch the last show
because that was the first time because
sometimes i get kind of
inebriated on the show but that was the
first time that i didn't
remember ending the show and i didn't
remember
the last hour like it never came back to
me the whole last hour of that show is
just a blank
yeah and i woke up at four o'clock in
the next the next morning and i was just
kind of like
yeah did i turn the computer like i
couldn't even remember turn the computer
off i didn't couldn't remember
and it amazed me because i think i
posted it on instagram and [ __ ] like
that i'm like holy crap go me because i
didn't remember
too yeah you're gonna don't call her
tiffy they know they know my ex-wife's
name how'd this [ __ ] happen
because i just said that was your
ex-wife okay all right dude that just
happened
like two minutes ago i said you just
called me by your ex-wife's name
okay have i ever called you by these
[ __ ] have i ever called you my man no
no no i have not for the record for the
record
and i was married for 15 years yeah and
i have never
she's trying to guilt-trip me i've never
called you by my ex-husband's name
ever yeah thank you it's just
now they're paid see this is how you do
it you're getting that sympathy money
you're getting that sympathy money
eight thousand [ __ ] if you feel sympathy
for jenny go ahead and pay her
i'm not gonna poison you
[Laughter]
not that i've thought about it but i'm
not gonna do it i'm not gonna do it
have i even i don't have i even shown
these [ __ ] tiff before
you have i have okay one time i don't
remember what show it was
it was uh three or four weeks ago yeah
you kept showing pictures
you kept putting them up to the oh yeah
that's right
that's right i was just kind of like
okay yeah
yeah okay i show pictures of everybody
that i talk to sometimes i'll show
pictures to
the friends and [ __ ] i have never i
don't you didn't like her
you don't think no you wouldn't like her
why is that
she's not like she was a matter of fact
the friend
you know melissa my friend who was her
friend
still knows her tells me that yeah the
one you visited in mississippi
yeah and the one that went to college
she just thought you wouldn't like her
no she's nothing like she was nothing at
all
she has she has evolved into a being of
evil
although she might have been on that
path anyway when i knew her
maybe she well you guys weren't married
that long no
it was only like a year i was married
before and i was married first i was
only here for you i was with her for two
years but i was only married to her for
a year
i was married for 15 years and we were
younger yeah we were young back then so
you know what i mean it's it's different
you know i mean it's different when
you're young i will well yeah it's a lot
different
i kind of feel like the person that i
was
in my 20s or even in my 30s yeah you're
not the same
i'm really not it's like a different
person yeah
exactly it's weird because you sometimes
look back and like i look back
at i was talking to my to my friend who
i've known since high school
the other day and she sent me a letter
that i had written to her in the 90s
yeah and i was like reading it and i was
kind of like holy crap
it seems like it was written by someone
else yeah exactly we got it even though
it was me
but it's like you were married for a
long time i wasn't see
and i was like 29. you know what i'm
talking about
i was 22 when i got married yeah i was
like 29
and she was like 24. all right
she's like 24 maybe a little bit younger
i think about 24
probably it's been a long time anyway
it doesn't matter she was cute though
she was cute in a day she was a cute
you would have liked her back in the day
yeah you liked her back in the day but
not now
no but you haven't talked to her in a
long time i haven't talked a long time
but she's nothing like she was evidently
i've heard about i was like
i don't know what happened to my
ex-husband yeah i haven't talked to him
since 2000
12. yeah when did we move in here
2011
2012. they're saying i turned to riva
not not internal evil it's over time
she's been married she's been married
she got married after we broke up
yeah yeah i haven't talked to my
ex-husband since
i think it was two thousand when did i
move out of my apartment and we
got this house 2012
right yeah about that i think it was
2012. i think the last time i talked to
him was when he was moving back
to the uk and he said
i'm leaving the car at the airport
because we had a car that i bought
well we both kind of bought it but i
paid more for it and he left it
thank you elsa and i break it off
she says you're prettier anyway i know
[Laughter]
but um yeah but but he
couldn't take it back to the uk so he
said well i'll just leave it at the
airport and you can pick it up and me
and him went to
the airport and picked it up i'm gonna
show him oh
what'd you do okay you [ __ ] it up
yeah that's her
she looks a little bit like a little bit
yeah you guys were the same type
actually
yeah let me see if i can find another
one
gotta understand this is when we were
very young though
a little bit like deborah harry a little
bit yeah yeah
zach says how did i meet a welsh guy to
begin with
this is so old school we were pen pals
back in the 90s
shortly after i graduated graduated from
high school
um i was still living in daytona beach
and i knew some guys around here but i
was kind of like i was i was always kind
of like into british [ __ ] like i
really liked british comedy i really
like british music and so i
joined a pen pal service this was before
the internet was widespread yeah goths
were on pimp house so yeah so um
so i joined like a british pen pal
service where
you would like so they'd send you this
like huge like
list of names of uh people in the uk
that had like your similar interests in
music and [ __ ] so i picked like
10 or 20 names off of there and like
wrote letters to them and he was one of
the people that wrote uh
back to me uh several other people wrote
back to me and i wrote to many of them
for many years
um but for whatever reason he was the
one that we kind of clicked with he used
to send me tapes of him talking and he
would like
um and then finally he said hey i'm
coming to florida you know do you want
to
like hang out or whatever so he came to
daytona and visited me and he just like
stayed and didn't leave because i was
that awesome
but you know [ __ ] happens i can't even
like i said i haven't
i feel bad that i haven't talked to him
in so long
but i don't know in a way that seems
like another person
yeah you know what i'm saying no now
[ __ ] sex in there she's creepy
zack that [ __ ] was not she was not
creepy she was awesome other one's the
guy going like she's cute the other guy
said i'd hit that
[Laughter]
tiff was cool she was very cool and um
she was just
i'm not gonna talk about it never mind
this is this is the people love this
[ __ ]
people love this [ __ ] i'm done with my
notes you can do whatever you want
she was a little skinny for me you know
she's a little skinny
all right nico says jenny needs a fresh
drink i do yeah well it's a world the
show's almost over
was skinny and she had a very it was
very popular look
back in the [ __ ] late in in the late
80s
90s even over to the late 90s
um for for [ __ ] like a hottie to be
skinny but with [ __ ] implants and she
was one of those
and uh she
she had a cool personality she was one
of the coolest girls in mississippi
that's a mississippi girl
from the coast around in the biloxi area
and i met her in new orleans at the in
the french quarter
she was very cool but um it just didn't
work out over time
that's that you know let's just say that
my job got in the way of a lot of it
yeah i mean i had to be in other places
uh
traveling and [ __ ] involved but uh
she also got [ __ ] you know sometimes a
woman when they're young to kind of take
advantage they kind of take everything
for granted and
well i get [ __ ] too but i have a
you're a very different
she was very different she's very
different now you never really gave me a
hard time
i only well i feel like i give you a
hard time because
i have a very um
i have a very stringent work ethic yeah
and a schedule to uphold for the show
for my books for
other things that we have to do and if
that is not
um oh bless you so and if that is not
like
adhered to yeah i get upset yeah that's
true
that's true but that that was nothing
compared to her yeah
yeah she's a little bit crazy too and
her mom was a little bit crazy which i
had to deal with her mom a lot
but uh yeah yeah louie says if there's
no kids involved why would you stay in
touch with your ex
that's right that's right no kids you
probably should not i i do feel like
i admire people that can still be
friends with her i don't have any hard
feelings about my ex
um he wasn't a terrible person
it was just you know it didn't work out
i met the guy i couldn't understand him
the accent was so thick i'm just like
what i mean
i was kind of like because i met you
when i was still married to him
even though like we were having problems
at the time and like
he um after he realized
that um we kind of were
getting together and he wasn't like
gonna be in the picture anymore
he kind of got vindictive and started
trying to spread rumors about me
in the scene which didn't work because
everybody knew
me and not him yeah so it's like nobody
believed it
it was [ __ ] hilarious because during
this time there were a bunch of these
little [ __ ] soy boys and [ __ ]
that were gutted for her harder than
[ __ ] and they were [ __ ] oh i had some
stalkers
all those kind of stories about me that
weren't true
about what a hoe i was that was special
and
stop it pooh what are you doing yeah i'm
not like i'm not gonna watch
it true it wasn't it wasn't true i'm not
gonna like name the guy because
because he's a nice dude but no and then
he apologized to me
he did later yeah he got like for
whatever reason he got like hung up on
me because i was i guess i was nice to
him at some
night or whatever and this was after me
and my husband separated
and like so i was nice to him and like
he kind of
got obsessed and he was like he would
text me like a hundred times a day like
not even exaggerating yeah and it kind
of got to a point where it was like i
was like
weirded out like i didn't think he was
going to kill me or anything but i just
i thought it was a little bit
weird she tried to tear that up you're
crazy you're going crazy
she's being bad yeah she's had enough
she wants this show to be
but yeah so there was kind of a
situation
and he kept like half of the [ __ ] he
would text me was like how
much he loved me thank you hayden oh my
god thank you
oh thank you very much bro what'd you
say he said did you get the rd 350
running
no the rd 350 okay look
i need some new top in for the motor i
got almost everything except little [ __ ]
i got to get a new top end for the motor
i got in to get a new crank
i got the [ __ ] cases i need to
[ __ ] get the magneto and all that
[ __ ] and the wiring harness set up
but if i had the wiring harness the
[ __ ] magneto and [ __ ]
because it was gonna be straight
kickstart i don't even think i was gonna
put a battery in it
and um get the [ __ ] top end the crank
i'd [ __ ] it could roll because it's a
rolling chassis already
i already painted it's just for some
reason man i hit a certain age and i'm
like oh [ __ ] it i don't want to do it
anymore
i don't know what it was i built a bunch
of motorcycles in a short period of time
and [ __ ] blew
and got sick of it or something
but i was looking at the prices getting
old getting old
i was thinking about in terms of top end
putting that back putting it putting a
banshee top in and a banshee
banshee [ __ ] crank in it out of a
[ __ ] snowmobile
damn four four-wheeler or is it a
snowmobile i forgot i think it's
four-wheeler
it was a lot more horsepower
because i like a lot of horsepower but
then i was [ __ ] thinking i was like i
don't know if that
i don't know if that chassis yeah
chances would handle it it's just that
i'm realizing that i'm dealing with a
bike that [ __ ] is not very fast and
when you start making that [ __ ] real
fast you're kind of [ __ ] overpowering
certain things i i
i don't know if this i don't know if the
handling geometry is good enough to
handle that kind of [ __ ] power
but it is [ __ ] very much throttle
dependent i mean you know
although i'm getting drunk and it's hard
for me to talk about things that are
technical
you'll be all right two-stroke you know
two-stroke all that [ __ ] power
happens way high up in the [ __ ] power
band it's either all or nothing and i
was [ __ ]
looking at this thing going you know
what when this thing's done it's gonna
be a [ __ ] death trap
it's gonna be a [ __ ] death trap so it
might be
more prudent if i to finish this thing
[ __ ]
with kind of like maybe just a little
bit above stock horsepower
keep it weak like maybe 30 40 horsepower
something like that something's real
manageable because i'd want to put those
[ __ ] badass expansion chambers on it
and everything you know
all right that's all i'm gonna talk
about glen that's it make me another
drink for a second i gotta talk i gotta
talk about some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
louie says that's all it takes for this
dude's jenny to smile
yeah well that's the thing like i'm a
nice person
i don't like to be an [ __ ] to people
but there comes a point where
i kind of feel like in my old age like
i'm almost 50
um that there's something to be said for
dudes like coming up to you and being
like hey did it and you just being just
like [ __ ] off yeah
right now just [ __ ] up like even if they
punch you or whatever it's like at least
you've established
that you do not want anything to do with
them because i feel like there's a type
of dude
that if you just so much as
be polite to them then they will just
run with it
so i feel like that was kind of the
situation like
you know what i mean it's like i said
i'm a nice person i try to be nice to
everybody
unless they're straight up a douche and
so this guy like half of the
where like three quarters of the
messages that he sent me
were how awesome i was and then the
other uh quarter were how
much you sucked yeah about how bad i am
because he knew that because we were
hanging out at the time
like i was kind of like who's making
stuff playing the field you were playing
the field we were doing some other [ __ ]
then but like
we were still hanging out he was saying
i was [ __ ] all these women and i
wasn't i wasn't [ __ ] him
yeah i was just friends with him yeah he
was jealous though
jealous because she liked me yeah well a
lot of girls
a lot of girls like me i wasn't i wasn't
screwing them though yeah
you knew he was talking about right who
particularly
tori oh he was talking about atari yeah
because at that time i don't know if i
told you this but tori was
trying to leave her boyfriend yeah yeah
yeah i remember that i remember that
tori was is our indian princess she's a
native american
her dad is uh in indian affairs at
washington dc
she's a [ __ ] really good-looking goth
girl
with a big [ __ ] gigantic mane of
[ __ ] colored hair
and she's a um
yeah right trying to remember what
nation indian chicken
it's one of the it's one of the like
northern ones
because she's she's almost like an
eskimo they're a whale hunting
yeah it's like an inuit almost yeah um
go ahead keep talking i'm trying to
remember
anyway she was [ __ ] really big into
the scene and she's always been this
[ __ ] kind of punk rock goth girl
she's awesome by the way yeah she's
super cool and she i mean she's just
like an
awesome person she's a lovely person she
was kind of in this [ __ ] up
relationship this one dude
and [ __ ] we were gonna go out but for
some reason one thing happened after
another the timing wasn't quite right
and i didn't really i liked the guy so i
wasn't gonna
[ __ ] him over by going out with his
girlfriend you know what i'm talking
about
yeah it was one of those kind of
situations if i didn't like him it would
have been a different story
yeah so i didn't do it you know what i'm
talking about um
what's it she's a macaw indian there you
go a macaw
indian that's what she is which
they look like they're like eskimos but
they have blue eyes a lot of them she
has blue eyes
because they never went to war with the
united states they were always an
american ally
this goes all the way back with like the
foundation of the [ __ ]
republic of california and everything
because i think
i don't know if they were part of the i
think they were still washington state
when that happened but it was still a
pretty much of a [ __ ]
wild territory when all that went down
but they're all still there you can look
to see them up you can see them on
youtube where she came from and they all
look like that
yeah did you know that yeah they all
look like her
um but anyway that's what that deal was
i do feel like you had because i had
many people
like warn me about you yeah even when we
were just like hanging out yeah
thank you michael thank you very much
michael it was so
weird and and i did feel like i mean i
didn't know you as well as i know you
now but
i feel like people were [ __ ] on you
for just like normal [ __ ]
they were [ __ ] on me for the [ __ ]
they were trying to do
like you didn't bang any like any
it wasn't excessive it was just like
normal [ __ ]
maybe even less than normal [ __ ] less
yeah you were you were 90
less of a hoe than a lot of other people
that i could think of yeah
you were probably less of a hoe than me
after i got
after my divorces it was about prestige
it was about prestige it was all like
rumors
yeah yeah it's what it was what it was
is that
they were talking about me because i was
attracting attention
so they were making [ __ ] up people well
here's the thing but here's the weird
thing
after a couple years later i heard me to
get all that [ __ ] vanished
and yeah i'm sorry about talking about
you like that yep you made this [ __ ] up
apologize
yeah like the dude that had like you
know [ __ ] texted me like for forever
yeah when and apologized to him yeah
it's like i said for making that [ __ ] up
from
he's like you know i i i misjudged you i
guess or something like that he said i
was in the bathroom i don't know what he
said yeah
he went up to you when he went to the
bathroom i don't remember exactly what
it was he was there when you came back
though
i gotta say like i i admire that that's
why i don't want to like say his name or
nothing like that because it's like he's
not a bad dude it's like you know he's
been in the scene like forever and it's
just like
you know he wasn't like super like he
didn't like [ __ ] come stalk me at my
work or nothing like that but it's just
like i like that he
you know came out and said hey i was
wrong about you yeah like not a lot of
people did that
he had no choice though that's true
because by that time
[ __ ] everybody you know you knew that
what he was saying was [ __ ]
by that time yeah i think the problem
with it was that
he was just trying to compete it was
just yeah well and like i said
you know you're a snappy dresser you
know you were a snappy dresser you would
come to the club you were a good dancer
you had a lot of female friends you
weren't sleeping with them but you had
like a lot of
women that were friends with you yeah
and i think that dudes saw that
yeah and didn't like it no so
they started spreading rumors like with
chicks they wanted to like well they
were all the girls that they liked
right and they were vying
some of them were vying for me but i
think that was the problem and
and and i'm real wise about which one
i'm going to go with
and you know all these women yeah you
know why i didn't bite
yeah you know why i didn't bite yeah i
mean there's each one of them kind of
had
different issues that weren't quite
[ __ ] on the up and up
because the scene has a bunch of what
we'd call characters in it they're
characters
yeah they're characters you know what i
mean that's good though you got to know
what you're dealing with
you know what i mean they're not they're
flawed people you know
and some of them might be good for an
evening or two but long term you don't
want to be with that
all right jenny won out over time
because she was a good long-term
investment because she was a good person
i'm a good long-term investor yeah a lot
of these a lot of these
women that we're talking about you know
what i mean visually they might be
stunning or attractive but they're not
good long-term investments because of
their character
they're not good characters well and
once you get they're gonna [ __ ] you
they have ulterior motives or [ __ ]
they have past that they can't run from
or they
just have bad behavior you know what i
mean yeah
there are other things yeah there's a
bunch of other [ __ ] so i'm not stupid
like that
once you get old i feel like that's a
young dudes it's a young dude's thing
you just because we do
and and we've seen that like i said you
know you're in your
you know you're 50 whatever yeah i'm
almost 50. yeah and i'm like you get to
a point where
like i did stupid [ __ ] when i was young
everybody did but you get to a point
where
like dudes in particular thank you
victor
i'm investing in jetties i am thank you
she gives all the money people
yeah i bought the shirts um yeah so
that's the thing it's like i feel like
younger people
you're kind of like allowed to do that
[ __ ] but young dude
she learned from that [ __ ] too yeah
young dudes i feel like if a woman is
hot
they will put up with yeah an amazing
amount of [ __ ] that they would not put
up with
if that dude was just like average
looking like so i feel like really hot
women can
have all kind of personality flaws and
get away with it with the young guys
though
well yeah that's what i mean but once
once you get into your 30s your 40s show
like that
you don't even know what it is you don't
have time for that yeah [ __ ] and i go oh
man
they can work with me no you don't need
that [ __ ] drama
because none of that [ __ ] is for free
you might think you'd be diving it off
into that [ __ ]
you can pay for it one way or the other
okay
you might be able to get it a couple
times for free but then all of a sudden
the [ __ ] starts piling up on you and
it's not for free one way or the other
it's either going to affect your
reputation it's going to affect your
health or it's going to affect your
wallet
or they're going to keep calling you
you'll never get rid of them there's all
kinds
don't do it don't don't do it just
understand who it is
before you [ __ ] get involved with
that [ __ ] that's just that's so and
that's always been
my [ __ ] motto well i like i said i
feel like a lot of dudes are blinded
young dudes mostly they're blinded by if
you're
a hot woman yeah you can get away with
an amazing i was about i was already a
neuro to that because i grew up in
brazil
where hot women were everywhere from my
age were like 14.
and there was no such thing as a
teenager in brazil back in the 80s
you're either a child or you were an
adult so i was in nightclubs about 14
already
you know what i mean chasing 14 15 year
old girls
so the idea of [ __ ] land is some hot
chick and when you're a foreigner you
have just
foreign an american and you have some
money a lot of money
especially compared to them you have a
huge [ __ ] social advantage
so yeah i became quickly experienced
with them you know i mean by the time i
was 17 you know what i mean i already
had good taste
and i knew how to defend myself so it's
kind of like accelerated evolution
very much in a way i grew up kind of
like a celebrity grows up
you know what i'm talking about well you
had a lot of money where you yeah i had
a lot of money when we were there my
family was very wealthy
yeah okay we're talking about in excess
in excess of two million dollars a year
in brazilian you guys had maids and all
that kind of [ __ ]
yeah so i was i was kind of waiting for
it i can't imagine
now that [ __ ] dissolved over time but
you know i mean because wealth and
wealth and success is a temporary thing
and it's things that have to be
maintained
but i grew up in that environment in a
[ __ ] developing country they called
it a developing country
so from an early age i abused that [ __ ]
but it wears off very quickly
you know what i'm talking about well if
you have it all the time it's just kind
of like it's not special
it's not special it becomes unspecial
very quickly
so but i think i think i think my family
made more than five million dollars a
year
when we were there yeah well like i said
you guys had a really nice yeah i could
have whatever i wanted you could have
you had maids and i ran from that [ __ ]
went to the army because i [ __ ] hated
it
yeah i hated it i just hated uh
you know and i'm not the only one a lot
of them [ __ ] trust fun kids they end
up killing themselves and [ __ ] like that
because
they hate having everything done for
them you never really develop a
character of your own louis says i've
been watching you guys for years but how
did tom end up in brazil
my mother was a secretary of the council
general of brazil she was part of the
state department
so after i let you know and i was in a
military academy at that time
and yeah that was when you were what
yeah in your teenage years 12
10 11 12. it went to signal hill
southern california military academy and
because of [ __ ] like family
backgrounds my mother kind of had like a
leg up she divorced my dad by that time
but she had a leg up in the [ __ ]
government service
and why she was on foreign assignment in
brazil she met an american guy
from michigan and he owned dumont dental
industries it was a division of curse
cybron corporation
which they made dental equipment got a
perch and drill bits and [ __ ] rubber
gloves and [ __ ] like that
so it was all part of the dental
industry
and um i was there for a while two years
then moved back to the united states
we were only there for about a year it
was during that time
or year or two years i think i think it
was two years
i think man it's been so long but i was
then i went to school in michigan during
that time
trenton michigan then we went back to
brazil
and because of all the [ __ ] weird
i was losing all kinds of credits
because when i went to high school in
the united states
most of my [ __ ] wasn't counted back in
brazil
because the school that i went to there
was a [ __ ] ib school which is
international baccalaureate so half of
my [ __ ] so i had to do a bunch of extra
high school
so i did another couple years of high
school back in brazil
in an international high school then
once i graduated from there
he went back to i went to detroit and i
lived there for about a year i was in
the goth scene and [ __ ]
having fun with some friends that i went
to high school with
and then
i got [ __ ] i can't remember exactly
what had happened
i don't remember why i left i went to my
dad's house
and when i was at my dad's house for a
couple months the [ __ ] first gulf war
kicked off and i went down on a whim i
was like that's it i'm going back into
the service because i was raised in a
military school
i said war is here i'm gonna go [ __ ]
make a war career
join the infantry and [ __ ] went to
war
but instead of going to [ __ ] uh the
first gulf war they sent me the [ __ ]
korea
yeah on the dmz though i'm glad i'm glad
they sent me the [ __ ] first and the
506th
which is the dmz uh battalion it takes
care of all the [ __ ] places at pamung
john
but they're associated with it where
they held all the peace talks so i was
right there on the [ __ ] border and i
got into all of that north korea [ __ ]
and then uh did that for a year and then
[ __ ] got
um sent to the 101st down to fort
campbell and did a mission and [ __ ]
sinai peninsula
got out ended up doing some uh
stuff in um for
four years i was in another four or five
years i was in boston
as a [ __ ] salesman and then man i'm
not telling my whole story i went i went
back
went back to the mississippi area in
mississippi louisiana era
area i did a bunch of [ __ ] different
[ __ ] with [ __ ] kind of like
contracting out for companies that were
involved in police and law enforcement
and training
all support stuff did that for a long
time and i came up here to
to eventually after my divorce and
[ __ ] [ __ ] kind of not playing out
with the contracts going on in
in in in louisiana i ended up here
in florida because uh
i thought at the time my mother was
dying
because she was living here she had
cancer yeah but she never died she's
still alive
she's still alive yeah but we thought
she was gonna die but i liked it here so
i stayed
yeah yeah but
once i once once i started going to the
scene in in orlando i was like i kind of
got like this better than new orleans
so i stayed it's weird because the scene
in orlando is very
it's it has drama like every other god
scene everywhere
but it's amazingly uh supportive
yeah like i like i like that it's kind
of like big city but small town at the
same time
you know what i mean like we know most
of the people here
yeah but you know like i said it's kind
of like
i don't know your your [ __ ] history
is like crazy like that you had maids
and like all that money and [ __ ] like
that i grew up in a [ __ ] trailer park
[Laughter]
you know it's like it's so sad yeah
all right i don't think we ought to go
ahead and shut this shut it down
everybody's having a good time
yeah but it's it's time to shut the show
down oh zach says
uh i forgot to tell you you're doing a
cookbook my half
uh l'oreal gavin actually published one
the butcher babe yeah if you want to
find it
i'm gonna look that up okay all right
were you moving that
just moved a little bit something stuck
there okay
all right so we're all um
coherent yeah i'm right i'm semi cool
here you're semi-coherent that's good so
i'm not going to be afraid to watch this
tomorrow
and we actually we actually did okay on
time three hours and eighteen minutes
yeah yeah we should probably end it i
probably yeah all right
so you guys like share subscribe you
guys enjoyed the show like share
subscribe on all your social media blah
blah blah if you want to
support the show please go to patreon
you get to vote in polls
that's a new thing you get to like vote
like what our next topic is going to be
what our next movie is going to be
also check out my new tomes of terror my
new book review show
which patrons will get to see tomorrow
morning but public will get to see
monday morning hopefully you guys enjoy
those
because i'm having a good time doing
them so
go and watch it and like it and all that
other kind of stuff
and we will see you on the next live
stream which will probably be tomorrow
afternoon
so we will see you later bye